It's always hard to stop a conversation
and then we started in a natural way
after you smoke pot at 10:00 in the
morning on a Monday.
It's just one of those things.
Lot.
Yeah,
it's too much going on.
We can't be asked to start and stop a
conversation.
That was pretty smooth.
It was just like,
hey,
we're going to go.
Yeah,
this is the pot pauses are weird,
man.
Like,
and start the show data that uh,
it's really,
you got to listen to a whole theme song
and then you going to wait.
And then like how long ago?
That was the wrong way to do it.
We made a few mistakes.
The big one was um.
Oh,
is that me?
Whoops.
I haven't done that in a long time.
I thought I had this close to swear to
God.
I come the apple thing when you hit your
apple TV press play on your fucking
itunes on your computer.
Does it?
Yeah.
All the time.
You're like,
no,
stop that one.
Just that one.
Oh No.
Both.
So if you have apple TV and the computer
open at the same time.
So if you're watching on TV and you have
a computer or if you have a quicktime
file on the desktop or starts playing.
Oh Wow.
How annoying.
Blockers for the sense of.
Sometimes even when it's closed,
it's still starts it up and eating.
My fucking phone started making my
computer ring the other day.
Company.
Yeah,
we were in here.
My computer is ringing.
I was like,
what kind of dog?
Shit.
Chilling out.
Watching a sure that I watch,
I guess.
Yeah.
Obviously I'm sure it's totally not
connected.
They already look at everything we do.
Come on,
come on.
We don't even notice it.
I know.
It's pretty nice making your computer
ring.
Do my phone and my computer ring.
They're connected in some way.
Something new.
Update new.
Made Mike fucking my phone.
Made my computer rang.
Like what?
What are we doing here?
Change your life.
We are just given into the Borg.
Why don't we just admit it?
Yeah.
Why don't we admit it?
Who's going to be the first one to get
their legs cut off for some new bionic
book?
Each of our buildings?
Yeah,
Bro.
You to get to keep your cock and balls
chopped off and have a fake legs,
broke his legs,
never get tired,
man.
Are you tired of walking all the time?
You get your cock and balls,
balls.
Most important part.
You want to keep these stupid meet
vehicles or do you want to get the cyber
2000 cyber 2002 legged system?
It's amazing,
man.
It doesn't even feel it'd be.
You totally feel like your own legs,
but they never get tired.
Dude,
you wouldn't even,
you would only need head and cock,
you know,
you could replace everything else.
I wonder.
Here's the question.
If you could live with everything else
being yes fingertips.
Um,
maybe one hand.
I'd like to hand
and cock phase.
Here's the thing.
If,
if,
if people are smart enough to start
manipulating bodies like that,
do you think they're going to keep the
same shape that we have now?
Oh yes.
Go round like the rod to from the New
Star Wars.
I don't think that's beneficial.
I was thinking that looks right.
Would there be a better designed than
this bipedal hominid form that we use?
Like would we get to a point where like
aesthetically,
like we started changing things on
people,
you know,
like have a chainsaw hands while I was
thinking like Minotaur bodies,
like clearly you know,
how much of you wants to be a person,
how many legs want run a lot faster on
four legs,
so the first guy to have four legs and
everybody's like Whoa.
And for no reason it doesn't make any
sense,
but girls are like,
that's hard to get lucky.
Some fucking freak DNA thing that pops
in a female's head when they see a man
with four legs and they just can't help
themselves.
Oh my God,
I just did this to get faster,
but this is nice.
Yes.
To asses,
you know,
if I got a minute or I would hire all
the viral companies and the,
and the PR firms and like get it out
there where it's an attractive thing.
Make It.
Part of this is that everyone says,
oh yeah,
yeah,
that's hot.
More legs.
So hotter,
higher,
higher like Leonardo Dicaprio to say it.
That could totally be done.
Yeah.
You've seen some of the crazy things
that people are doing with their bodies
these days.
Definitely want something different.
One,
we'll one.
We'll tude.
There's so many like weird body
modifications today.
I was jealous when those shoes with the
wheels came out of the bottom of the
shoes.
We'll never made it for adult sizes.
So I was pissed about that.
To make feet with wheels on it.
You should start a company licensed the
product.
Yeah.
That's a good idea actually.
They'd be so much.
Why is it no fun to do it as an adult?
I don't understand the problem.
Straight away.
You can't fucking.
You're not supposed to be enjoying so
far.
You're,
you're a grownup.
Supposed to stop the one with chores
wheeled around the mall.
I can asshole
wieland thing,
man.
I would love it.
But you got to stay on your back.
Feet seems like an awkward way to stand.
It's probably bad for old people like
pop in back wise.
You look back a lot of strain on the
back like that.
She,
Tyson wiping out on that.
Uh,
that
dude those things.
The first time I got on one,
I can do one now,
but the first time I got on one it was
at the comedy store.
And um,
this dude who's a comic,
what is his name?
Jamie know that dude's name.
You know what I'm talking about,
right,
sir?
Ben Kingsley,
I don't know.
Might have been.
I forgot his name.
Nice guy.
Anyway,
he,
uh,
he has a white one who's tooling around
the parking lot with tate and I go,
how,
how
hard is it to do?
And he goes,
try it.
I got it.
I couldn't imagine doing it.
I got on and I was like,
there's no way I'll ever get good at
this is fucking insane.
Like,
what is it?
Just two wheels and basically it's
essentially,
it's some form of a gyroscope and it's
like those scooter things that they have
the mall.
What are those things called again?
Segues,
segways,
segway things.
Have you ever ridden one of those?
No.
Really Fun.
Kevin James had one on the set of that.
Zookeeper moving.
Yeah.
He actually had a couple of them and he
would zoom around the parking them.
Do Dare fucking fun.
They're really cool,
but when they run out of batteries,
you go flying.
Then another stop brighter.
Do the battery just breaks.
If the battery runs out of juice,
you go down hard on it because it's the
only reason why it's keeping you up,
but you're not doing that yourself.
Like it's a gyroscope like gets it's
counter balancing you as you really
can't be a stable.
Oh,
you could definitely fall.
You definitely can fall,
but it's really easy to ride like you
don't.
I hope I'm saying gyroscope properly or
explaining the physics behind.
No idea what a gyroscope is to be
honest.
Scooters it called.
Yeah.
What would you say that it's run like a
gyroscope?
Is that.
Am I making things?
It's a gyroscope of the thing that you
get to the air and space museum.
The thing that's keeping balance like
house.
Can you pull up the definition of
gyroscope?
Just so I don't feel like an idiot.
I just want to know if that's what it is
because I've always been saying that.
But,
um,
now that I'm,
I'm,
I'm thinking while I'm saying,
am I right that that's a gyroscope,
I have no idea what a gyroscope covers,
whatever it is,
whatever this technology they've
invented for segue there,
you pull the string and it stays.
It stays spending forever.
Yeah.
The orientation of the access is
unaffected by tilting the rotation of
the mounting.
Okay.
So that does make sense.
But also in like drones to keep them up,
right?
Oh.
Really?
GPS to help them keep up.
Right to the good Lord.
Was the drone almost switch gear?
Yeah,
we watched it.
What the fuck,
man?
You remember the guy who died in the
segway guy died.
We went off a cliff at one of the guys
that own the company or the inventor of
it
died on a segway going off a cliff when
he went to patent that thing my friend
worked at the patent office.
When he came in,
he didn't,
he didn't submit any,
like a blueprint.
You just brought one in and had
everybody write it.
First of all,
why is he near cliff?
Why is he like got on the road?
Oh,
he went off the cliff then.
Off-Road segue.
Oh,
what a terrible idea.
Until they have it.
I don't know.
But if they do,
that's a terrible idea.
Road segway because unless those things
are like way improved,
I would think that the batteries,
like if you couldn't rocks and shit,
giant tires.
The idea of like running over a rock and
hitting your electrical system.
Me As someone with zero knowledge of
even how electricity works.
I'm just going to comment on this
already.
You know,
like I don't know what the fuck
electricity
is.
I know you can't stick a fork in the
hole or you die.
That's what I
have such a fucking idiot.
People like.
Hold on because your feet though.
Connect like shut up.
You don't know.
He was this dude.
What are you showing me?
The TV shredder.
It looks like a four.
We'll segue segue.
It's just real.
Look at where to hold gas masks.
Looks like Halo.
This is like a fucking.
Oh my God.
He's wearing a business suit.
This is insane.
It's got tires like a tank.
That is so crazy.
That desert video.
You gotta show me a video though.
I think it goes sidesaddle sports.
Yeah,
I guess right.
That guy in that position.
Yeah,
that seems weird.
That seems like a weird way to stay.
Maybe it's just that one picture.
Look at this fucking little mini tank.
That is bad ass.
Wow.
Like fucking why not,
right?
Oh,
he's going up the wall.
No way there was going to jump.
Just a seesaw.
A seesaw wise is one of the dumbest
tricks,
but why this is to show that he can go
over obstacles.
Oh whoa.
No Way.
They're going,
oh my God.
Like nothing.
Hell yes.
Oh,
this thing is actually really bad
podcasts over.
Let's go.
Easy.
Dude.
This is crazy.
What is it called?
This a DTV shredder.
Oh,
that one.
The thing.
It's not even that heavy.
Like when he falls down and she wouldn't
just fell down,
look like he just picks it up and moves
it.
Like it's not that big of a flip back
on.
Yeah.
Look,
we're not talking a motorcycle.
That's why the fuck do you want a
fucking commercial for this?
Seems like we're doing a commercial for
those.
I've never even heard of this until
seconds ago.
I swear.
This is bullshit.
I see what you're doing,
dude.
Fucking product place.
DTV slash job broken right now.
You get 10 percent off
free shipping.
What the fuck is that man?
That's a shredder plates.
Some 14 year old boy got like 10 million
bucks
and said I'm starting my own company.
But you have a rapper who had about
rappers trick.
Couldn't everything in their home.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's the white version of it.
There it is.
The
atvs or like a white man's?
Yeah,
like an ATV.
If you're like,
if you're white trash and you got like
really powerful Atvs,
like you are running shit.
You got a good piece of land.
We could just drive through mud.
Fuck yeah.
Let's go to bobby's right.
Those atvs.
Medan.
That's fun and shit.
I don't want those atvs.
Oh my God.
They're so fun.
Really.
Three wheel things will there four
wheels,
but that.
Those like motorcycle motorcycle things.
Yeah.
Do Funny Shit.
I've,
I've been in a bunch of different kinds
of little buggies to jumping and stuff.
He.
Oh No,
no,
just you driving through the woods and
um,
they're really fun.
Oh
yeah,
yeah.
It's really bouncing,
but they can get out of anything and
they'd go into the woods and drive over
logs with them and shit.
Hell yeah.
You take those things up in Canada and
my friends in Canada,
the rivets that run this hunting camp
and Canada,
they have an argo and argo is like a
mini tank.
It's the,
it's,
it goes amphibian,
it goes through the water.
Lily,
two things.
My friend John Rivett from up in Canada,
so he needs it.
He goes moose hunting.
So they,
they'll,
they'll kill a moose and they have to
drag it out of the woods and they have
it on this fucking mini tank.
Whoa dude.
What?
You've have to see this.
Then they have different wheels form,
like sometimes they have like wheels,
like giant truck tires,
but other times they put tank treads on
them and they looked.
They can go deep into the woods.
They just drive through shit.
Like you could buy a tank,
but sounds fun.
See you pull up a video of an argo so I
could show him what.
What he's talking about.
These dudes,
the rivets,
they have all sorts of Atvs,
but this argo is the mother.
This is the mother.
Like if you're stuck,
this motherfucker will get you out.
It's the mother.
It just goes deep into the woods.
It's a tank.
Fucking small tank gets over everything.
Everything.
Blogs.
Look at it,
look at it.
Look at it.
Okay.
This is one of 'em.
This is.
They have
to go into the water.
See the tank treads?
Yeah.
Some of them just tilt it.
You can drive through water with these
fucking things.
Wow.
Bill.
They had,
I don't know.
It's some hillbilly shit.
Whoever's making them.
You know they're appealing to
back that up.
Backed it up.
She could see that.
Where the one has tree.
Look at that right there.
We can see the
trees.
No,
he's gonna tank tread.
There's tank tread on these things.
I mean it's a fucking tank tank for the
forest.
Wow.
I see girls right now would be so angry
if they were here.
Who Cares?
Why
don't live in the forest,
ladies?
I'm so sorry that we don't see things
the same way.
This is like for a girl going through
creeks and shit would be cool like that.
Will it be the female equivalent for
something like this?
Like awesome handbags,
girls who have bought some shoes,
shoes thing,
right?
Be a shoe thing,
man with money.
Older man with money in a heart
condition.
Oh my God.
You have got to see this.
What he barely breathe.
She bad.
His wallet is terrifying.
That,
that,
that some old dudes like that really are
preyed upon like that.
Yeah.
Nobody protects them.
No,
there's no like guys come on and they
can't make their own decisions.
I know a dude who got taken really older
dude,
but so few of a girl.
No,
he had a younger or younger girlfriend
that he met on one of those weird dating
sites and uh,
two years and she was involved in his
business.
Hundreds of thousands of dollars went
missing.
It's just got to this weird state.
He had a jess and jettison the
experience.
You know,
I am in its old dudes.
It's old people in general,
you know,
he started getting older,
he truly don't want to be alone and if
you're really old and you're wealthy and
you just find some girl who seemed so
nice,
but every time she makes your teeth
start,
just start feeling weird diarrhea and I
don't know what's going on.
Is something wrong with.
Maybe you're anxious because of the new
girl.
Maybe it's just,
maybe I just,
you know,
I haven't been having sex since my wife
died and I'm 85 years old now and I
can't believe this girl even wants to be
with me.
I mean it's just what a treasure and
what a blessing from the Lord.
But God,
every time she makes me,
he doesn't want to admit it.
You okay baby.
We're still gonna do it.
Do you not think I'm hot anymore?
He's in baby.
I love you.
I just know I'm 85 years old.
One second.
I just got asked blood slowly.
She's eaten through his insides.
I,
those,
those fucking shows like those um,
uh,
murder shows where they talk about like,
no,
no.
Like,
um,
when you talk about like a different
people that it did like a,
like there was one that was a nurse that
was purposely poisoning all of the
people that she was taken care of too,
that they were just crazy.
She crazy.
She was crazy too.
Is purposely poisoning patients to go to
work.
Yeah.
I don't think she was doing it to get
out of work.
I think she was just killing people.
I think she was just crazy.
It just was a few years back.
But the idea that someone would,
uh,
would want to consciously,
slowly kill someone with a poison like,
Woo,
Woo.
There want to just move on with your
life,
bitch.
Leave that poor guy in the bed alone.
No,
she,
she got off on it or something.
Something.
She was killing them while they were in
her care.
They were thinking about what it'd be
like.
Oh God.
It's dark.
It's,
it's amazing how few people kill people.
Really,
when you think about it.
I'm mad people get at each other and a
few people actually get killed.
Awesome.
Well,
awesome.
Fucking hanging in there,
man.
You know,
I mean think about how many times I walk
around and no fear of any physical
violence.
Yeah.
Almost never.
You have to be in the total wrong place
at the total wrong time or drinking
if you're drinking anything and
especially if you're one of those guys,
but I just free to walk around with
plenty of money in my pocket.
Yeah.
That's for anyone to just being like
everyone has a wallet.
Like you keep your cash cashman.
How long before?
That's not real anymore.
How long before paper money is gone?
That's kind of becoming right.
I'm ready for the trip.
Wow.
You're ready to give in to the board,
which is chip.
Someone's ready to give it to the board
and get some more legs.
You've ever seen those videos of the
order for the phone to work,
you have to get a horse leg it chip in.
That's what they're gonna do it
eventually.
Like,
okay.
Anyone who hasn't still have the chip in
and the horse legs,
we're going to.
We're going to give you free ones now
because everyone has to be on TV.
It would be like certain things you
couldn't get,
you couldn't get on the internet
anymore,
so they will deprive you of your
services.
Got To join that board saying my phone
will no longer work overseas,
but if you want an overseas phone,
they think they can get me one.
It's hilarious.
If you don't know,
Ladies and gentlemen,
Ari should.
Fear has done one of the bravest things
that any man has ever done.
He went from an iphone to a flip phone.
The chunkiest little 1979 technology
flip phone at the time.
It was super advanced.
Like what?
Your sporting in your pocket at one
point in time.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's undeniably.
Yeah.
I just like super advanced.
I had to find this one.
The first was just the free,
like best buy.
Go get it over there.
Yeah.
You started off with a regular one when
you had to do like four presses to get
an s.
How is it possible?
That was really,
really tough.
It's stupid.
This double flip is the future man.
Yeah.
Well you know what?
The real future is word recognition.
Oh yeah.
Whole typing thing.
It's so stupid.
It's gone.
It's on its way out.
It's so close.
They're so good now.
Like as far as showed me,
it was dead on.
I use it for notes all the time.
I'll say something into notes and I
just,
it comes out almost perfect.
Like weird things get spelled wrong if
it's a weird name or something like
that,
but that's to be expected.
It spells it phonetically.
Got Ra got red.
You know,
what else did Washington Post?
Is that what it was to wash it?
But it's already should fear was a
goddamn answer to a crossword puzzle,
ladies and gentlemen.
So suck it haters.
My mom and sister said it's a me.
It's a layer.
So they were getting all sorts of phone
calls.
Yeah.
And I was like,
no way.
It's such a.
that's such a non comedy.
Yeah.
That's.
You've transcended son.
So unquestionably.
You've now transcended.
That's like a
comedian show seven across.
Weird.
Said you're famous.
You're on TV.
What do you expect that,
that you haven't been there enough for
someone to get it here.
Don't suck it.
Yeah.
You're doing the right thing though.
I liked,
I liked the fact I.
I would never do what you're doing with
your phone,
but I like what you're doing.
What you're doing is you're looking at
the data and deciding,
okay,
how much willpower do I have?
Not Enough.
Fuck this.
Yeah,
there you go.
That's how.
That's where to put it.
I analyze the stats on my life and I was
like,
oh,
I can't stop.
But you did it very intelligently.
Like it's very difficult to do.
It's very difficult for people to not
just look at some weird addiction that
they might have,
but to say,
okay,
even though there's all this amazing
convenience of being able to buy movie
tickets and being able to check websites
and answer emails on your phone,
it's not worth it.
That's the justification.
It's not worth it.
It's too much.
Well,
you know how when you see someone on TV
smoking cigarettes,
you never really smoked,
Huh?
No,
I never spoke.
Only smoke.
When you see somebody just triggers
like,
oh,
I need to smoke to you,
get in your car.
Some people smoke no matter what,
just or whatever.
I wanted the comedy store at smoke.
You know,
it's funny though,
when I see people get high,
it does the opposite.
It makes me not want to get high go.
My God.
Do I sound that stupid?
You know,
because sometimes you'll say things when
you're high and as you're saying,
let me like,
like you would if you were to go,
oh my God,
he's an idiot.
But believe me,
I'm saying,
Oh my God,
I'm an idiot.
Come say as I'm saying it,
I'm thinking I'm an idiot sometimes.
I'm like,
this is somebody should write this down
or lift the media because it's brilliant
here the next day.
And you're like,
what?
I did a scene on news radio once with
Bob Costa,
who's a very nice guy.
Bob Cost is great.
He's very,
very intelligent guy too.
And we had the scene and um,
I uh,
he beats me up pillar custard,
flip me.
He does this like judo flip and go into
my ass for some strange reason.
Um,
but afterwards we were all out talking
and while we were talking I had smoked
pot and I was rambling to him
as I was.
I remember talking to him about dupont
making the chemical compound for nylon,
like at the same time when they made
hamp illegally,
some stupid ass minimum that I'm like,
shut bombs,
mom,
words coming out of my mouth,
I'm going to shut.
My brain is telling you,
your brain is telling you.
Stop it.
Shut up.
Just A.
Oh,
I don't know.
I mean he was,
he's a gentlemen and I'm sure he didn't
even call me on it.
I just realized that while I was doing
it.
Then you have to be like,
this is a super nice guy.
He's a really a really interesting guy.
Very,
very smart.
You know,
certain dudes like you talked to,
you go,
oh,
okay.
Fucking sharp.
Yeah.
There's a few guys like that.
He's a very sharp guy and he's a,
he's in an interesting position to as a
a sports commentator who also gives like
really well thought out opinions,
agree with them or disagree with them
about gun violence.
About a lot of other things,
but like important social issues.
Yeah.
Bob Costas.
Oh,
you know what I'm talking about place?
I think it's hip hop Costa.
I thought it was just another person
guy.
Yeah.
Bob Costas.
You gotta see the diaper guy?
The diaper guy.
Who's diaper water?
Bob Constants is the guy that doesn't
like football.
Right,
and Marv Albert.
I have no idea.
Does that.
He used to do that late night.
Show it later with bulk costs.
That's something like that was.
It was late night for a little while.
Super fucking smart guy,
man.
How dumb is that billboard for the late
night show where they're putting makeup.
That daily show girl be a girl.
Oh,
the one we were looking at.
Well,
you know,
they're just trying to get your
attention.
If it says like,
if you don't like it,
you're sexist or if you don't watch it,
you're sexist.
Even the name of it full front,
it's just like,
come on,
let him let him fucking just be good
hosts.
All of them.
All the minorities,
they just keep pushing them into like
being that thing of girls or minority.
Yeah,
girl TV.
That's an interesting way of putting it.
I've never heard a girl be described as
a minority even though they're 52
percent.
Yeah.
That the underrepresented on television,
what's it?
I would see a ratio on TV.
Yeah.
I have no idea.
When you say underrepresented,
like less than half the people on TV are
girls.
Yeah.
Really?
Standup is a lot more to do.
It's really.
Show me more about what you think about
movies or TV shows.
It was very few walking dead.
Women have an even number.
They have an even number of boys and
girls,
you know,
and somehow those people aren't hooking
up like what do we.
Not Forever.
I remember that couple barely and they
just fall deeply in love while they
fight off the zombies.
Get the fuck Outta here.
They never even filed.
Land was watching him in that one
episode.
He was just staring at them.
Fuck.
Oh,
that's right.
The comedian,
Josh.
Josh,
Josh is looking at and let them look.
Do you remember how we worked with Josh
would do that Gig?
Was it Duncan?
Might've been Duncan on me and uh,
we're in Arizona.
Yeah,
we were in Arizona and this was,
I think this was a d has no show
started it,
but I don't know the way,
the reason I went out on the road with
Joe Rogan is because he needed a second
person to open for him because Diaz was
at best 70 slash 30 to show up.
It was more than that.
He was more than that.
In all fairness,
there was only a few instances where it
didn't work out,
but I get stuck with nobody.
So you'll find the hub to case he showed
up.
I'll have to no big deal.
I'd Joey and I always felt like I have
an obligation to let joey be Joey.
What great.
When it's like,
Oh,
you might not show up today.
I'll just hire more people.
This is your job also.
We don't have this problem.
I knew like even way back in the day
that show he was special special guy and
he's special.
He's important for everybody.
Yeah.
You know,
he's like an engine and he's beautiful.
He's,
if you get close to him,
he's beautiful.
He's the best.
That kind of shines like inside like
this.
Why we all love to be around them
because you can,
you know,
if you're.
Even if you're busy or something like
this will be a 92nd phone call.
He's getting phone calls every day.
Yeah.
I mean he's a classic original,
but he,
you know,
he had problems back then.
But you saw something,
right?
I knew it.
I just knew it.
Oh Man,
this guy just needs.
He just needs to be.
Just leave him alone.
He'll figure it out.
He's closing my storyteller show again,
stir.
We're going to end the season with them
every year.
He's a monster.
He could do that forever,
by the way.
Yes.
He never runs out of storage.
It's insane.
I've never met anybody who I've known
him for what fucking almost 20 years and
he just always has new stories and there
and people will go,
this didn't have like,
yeah,
no.
He gets verification,
Verification.
Fucking call people up,
put him on speakerphone.
Tell him that fucking time.
Verification.
Joey Babaloo.
No,
in fucking north Bergen has these,
these conversations with people.
Verifications,
Verification,
triple ecology for verification.
That's right.
Was it.
I don't remember what it was,
but was the verification from onstage?
She calls you and you were at the
Improv?
Yeah.
What did I.
What was it?
This girl said,
oh,
we're not friends,
and I said,
I have my phone or something like that.
That's exactly right.
The fact that I'm getting on the phone
proves it.
Oh yeah.
It was a heckler.
Who's being mean to him?
Nobody's better with the hecklers and
triple,
triple.
He's franchise.
He's been in the trenches.
Yeah.
Diaz
Tripoli's a comedy store at dude.
Those comedy store guys,
especially us from like the nineties,
there was no.
Nobody was.
There was no crowd control.
Completely get off like there's no one
fighting for 10 minutes.
No one's even telling him to shut up.
How come fucking Holtzman got knocked
out?
Oh,
I remember.
He got.
He got punched in the face by someone's
bodyguard.
Ultimately one time tackled somebody
walking by the front row and the
original room and they walked in between
the front row of chairs and the table
chairs.
You know,
this was one of the words like it's a
stage one,
like with the tables,
so they're walking through there and he
saw them.
He just leaned over and grabbed onto
their shoulders and just left his body
weight drop.
I just brought him to the ground.
We're just going back to their seat.
Let me ask you this.
As a responsible person and an adult,
if you're running that business,
do you fire a gun check theirs?
Is that how you look at it?
Can Be like you can't.
That's why yelp reviews of comedy clubs
and some of the greatest things in the
world because they point out stuff that
you'd be like.
They're doing it as a yelp review of a
business,
but they're like.
Literally one of the employees said,
I hope I die in a fire when I'm going
home.
It's like,
imagine if a waiter set out to you and
then they're like,
oh,
you're talking about David Taylor came
from running you out of there and now
he's trying to hurt you,
so you think about it on the way home.
I don't want your business that you're
running out of there too.
You were probably a dick enough to be
like,
we don't want you back.
That's the most important.
What will you.
You can run into Dick's man,
and a lot of times it's just people that
don't know how to behave.
Like Chapelle was at the store the other
night and some guy kept yelling shit out
at.
I'm in the crowd.
Started yelling at the guy to shut the
fuck up.
That's both.
Oh,
was he was just so obnoxious,
but he just couldn't believe he was
talking to Dave Chappelle,
you know,
he's just drunk and he fucked up and the
people around him were responding and it
started getting Shitty,
but the star never had anybody to like,
you can't do that at the Improv.
They will grab you and they'll pull you
out of there.
Like they,
they like was this comedian,
so we're outside fucking smoking pot.
No one's parent attrition.
We're worried about talking to this
chick.
No one's paying attention.
You have to get a door guy.
Yeah,
but you know what?
I would say that it's way less necessary
today than it's ever been before.
The crowds have been amazing at the
store lately.
They also sort of,
okay,
here's the thing.
This is why Canadian crutches better
too,
because it's if you go into it and like
your listeners good with an
understanding of like,
here's the etiquette of what it's like
to be in a comedy show.
Like I sort of get it already.
Then they're just like a base level
better crowds.
Like I know you're supposed to shut up
and laugh and that's it.
Some people didn't get that message
going on though,
man.
That's part of what it is.
Some people,
they don't just don't know that yet.
Like what?
Like what is.
No one else is doing this.
Yeah.
I think
it's hard for some people that grew up
around morons.
You know,
if you grow up like exclusively around
morons and you've been responding to
morons or whole life,
then all of a sudden you're drinking
dave Chappelle's onstage.
You can act like a moron.
You,
you don't even know why you're doing it.
Like as it's coming out of your mouth,
you're like,
who is this asshole representing the
great spirit that is inside?
And I used to have more problems like
right after Chappelle show with a.
They would yell at those catchphrases at
him.
Oh,
he had a real problem once it was at the
House of Blues I think,
or something like that.
One of those places.
And yes,
young tour.
Yeah.
I remember people kept yelling out,
you know,
all the different phrases,
and she's like,
what?
Can't go anywhere at this.
Yeah.
What was the Big One?
What was that Big One?
I'm Rick James Bitch.
That was one.
They kept yelling at him.
He had,
when he came back from Africa or
whatever,
he had a show at the store,
the comedy store,
and it was mobbed that everybody's are.
Soundgarden came and Bruce Willis came.
Yeah,
I was mobbed and that way oversold and
uh,
the fire department showed up and it was
like trouble,
but they just wanted to sit on the
steps,
watch while he was the biggest thing
that was that.
But there was Shrek.
They told everybody,
you say a word and you're gone.
And there was a line out the door,
people not being able to get in.
Well,
and when magical was on,
I think he had two guys open for a
magical.
It's a black guy,
I forget who.
And then he went on,
um,
somebody heckled a little bit from the
front row and they just yanked him right
out.
Then somebody came right at,
got a front row seat because was just
fucked up.
Yeah,
man,
I think people are learning.
Yeah,
I get it.
If you don't like the person who's on
stage.
I've,
I've lived outside,
go get a cigarette and come back in and
said I,
I'll sit and watch the show.
And if someone is not doing well,
can you say something?
If your waiters being super rude to you
or somebody,
a plumber is being an asshole to you,
like,
hey man,
you're being a dick it out,
but not if it's ruining everyone else's
experience.
You know,
like a movie.
Go outside and complaint.
Well,
it's just,
it's not necessary.
If other people were enjoying it for you
to enjoy pleasure.
Yeah,
and that happened sometimes.
You mentioned leading star wars going,
this is a kid's movie I don't like.
This is for kids.
Kids Go,
who are you rooting for me?
But again,
we know that because we're in the
business.
I think for a lot of people this is all
they don't understand and then there's
also people who will tell you later,
you should be able to hear and losing.
We were up on stage.
You should be able to handle anything
they throw at you.
It's like one of the ways I had to
handle this is to make you leave by an
off duty cop who's working with
some weird thing.
When people tell you what you're
supposed to be able to do,
like as a comedian,
you're supposed to be able to handle it,
that magic going to a restaurant,
throwing a plate onto the floor,
and so will,
you know,
because deal with spills all the time,
don't you?
You should be able to handle it.
Somebody literally said when,
when the subject of stealing jokes came
up,
look,
you should be able to write more jokes.
I remember someone saying that like,
Oh,
it's fucking so simple.
Yeah.
So what are the other things?
Like you have a job before the boss
who's abusing you.
Well,
you should be able to get a better job.
Yeah.
What?
I haven't been a job
but a job
rapes,
mess hall commentary,
you know,
days,
asshole,
commentary.
That's all it is.
I like to just walk away from those
people.
You can do it online,
but we're trying to educate you.
Get out of here.
That's so funny man.
It's so true.
God.
Right.
We should draw.
You told me early on when you started,
like really like what you would be
vicious with Pete with those
hecklers.
Don't you feel bad?
You were like,
they've already shown them they're
assholes.
So No,
no mercy,
no reason to show mercy.
What they're doing is trying to be mean,
like they're yelling shit out,
trying to interrupt,
and a lot of them,
the reason why they're doing it is
because they just want attention.
They know it's not even what you're
saying.
They just,
for whatever reason,
they wanted to do an open mic night.
They never did it.
They got drunk and here they are and
they feel like I'm going to fucking get
disarmed.
She fear this guy can't handle what I'm
coming with them.
Can you fly around the room with those
times?
Did I just do gay guys at the stand?
And they were mad at me because it was
one of those things with drugs will
mishear one word,
you know?
And they'll just be like that.
No,
no.
I was saying I don't like people who
hate black people and black people now
and like,
no,
shut up.
It's one of those and they were just
being angry and give me the mainstay or
all the time and the standard is so
small that you can see everybody.
It's pretty good.
And uh,
and then I was like,
but you guys don't like this.
I was like,
I said something like,
first smile I got out of you.
And they're like,
well,
whatever.
And I just started calling Mr and Mrs
poopy pants had just like,
belittling them.
It's just so fun.
And watching them get angrier and
angrier.
We just talk over people.
They're just angry.
Well,
what were they doing?
Just gonna be so mad.
Like just giving me means mean mugs.
You've seen that when it's like,
I'm just going to try to show you how
mad I am.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Things like that.
I had a woman in Calgary,
she was bitching about everybody.
The whole open opener should come.
Yeah.
And it was like,
how you got to be quiet?
And then she did that thing with like,
next Joe and I'm like,
beat it.
You're out.
Get Out,
get the fuck out now.
What is that going to be above this
show?
I just railed on it for like 10 minutes
and I had to stop by the white crowd.
This is not coming out of your time,
so the clock stops.
Next joke.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It's like you don't want to be here.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Just so weird because you can go to like
the most amazing movie,
but if you're sitting next to someone is
going
to happen.
Oh,
you fucking live.
Who saw that?
Common Stallone.
He found a way to get that.
That rock pick into the side of the
mountain.
Just as he's hanging off of it,
pulls himself up,
be quiet,
grabs a log,
and drags himself over the top of the
cliff.
That could happen.
Right?
She
Guy,
this guy in Scotland threatened to sue
me.
Oh,
that's wonderful.
Yeah,
because I told his wife who was.
She was ugly.
Did you hear what happened in Canada
with that?
With Mike Ward?
Do you know the guy getting sued by
tribunals?
Yeah,
I like him a lot.
Was Great.
Which one are you talking about?
The one with the guy I'm cursed out the
lesbians and set a bunch of uh,
gay things to them.
No,
don't called him dykes.
Something along those lines.
And there was like a nasty exchange
trans guy and this girl and I'm the
woman sued and apparently I believe one
and I don't know,
like the specific mental damages.
Well I think she sued for like Jamie see
if he could pull that up.
I don't want to talk.
I don't know exactly what the charges
were but it was everybody was like Whoa,
like,
and she won.
I think she ain't gonna Award like
$10,000 or something.
Well then it becomes a thing where it's
like you either have to make everyone
sign a release for coming to a comedy
club or just saying you're going to kill
the art form as Jimmy pulls it off.
You can't take any more risks.
I don't want to misquote anything.
So I want to make sure I say this
incorrectly,
but it was a story I just,
I don't know,
I'll tell you what happened was to Mike
Ward,
French Canadian comic,
and so he was doing this,
there was this kid who was like,
make a wish kid,
whatever.
And uh,
they were like,
he's going out and it was a big like on
TV is like a coke campaign.
And then,
uh,
Mike had a bit about the 10 years later
this kid's still alive and he's like,
I want my money back.
You know,
it started going off because I was
fucking 23 now.
No.
And uh,
and I think so fucking.
And the kid said he got made fun of
because of it.
Oh my God,
it wasn't cool.
Jesus was like,
well,
sorry man,
you were like a celebrity and I'm going
to make fun of that stuff.
And he got taken to a tribunal is going
right now to a French Canadian tribunal.
Oh No.
Oh my God.
What are they suing them for?
Charging them with or what are they
doing a signing up for?
I don't know the exact charges,
but it's either 80 grand or more.
They're sort of for,
but the problem is then that just makes
anything off limits.
It makes any sort of subject where you
have no idea.
Well,
here's the thing.
How do you attach a monetary number two,
that slurs fo force comic to pay $15,000
more than I thought.
Tirade of ugly words against lesbian
patron after appeal falls flat.
Wow.
No appeal.
Appeal fell flat.
They didn't win the appeal.
Yeah,
so I think he lost human rights tribunal
there.
That's what Mike has been brought up
into a human rights tribunal.
What is going on Canada?
What the fuck you do?
Lasting physical and psychological
effect.
What's the physical effect?
We'll see.
I don't know.
I would say,
here's one thing.
If this woman came to a show,
okay,
let's let's,
let's be honest about this,
and,
and he just started to register the
worst case scenario.
I'm on her side.
If she,
if she's sitting there with her
girlfriend and she didn't do anything,
she's saying a bunch of lesbian shit to
her and being mean to her and just being
an asshole and you know,
guys have done that,
right?
We all know comics,
W we've all seen bad comics do things
like that or take attempts,
you know,
trying to be funny and it's just
defensive.
If you paid money to see something like
that,
no matter what it is,
whether
it's a black joke,
whether it's a,
you know,
a joke about Asian people and you're
getting your,
you feel like abused joke about their
height.
Whereas a line after that and that way
really a matter of what is being said,
it's not like just a blank subject,
right?
We can't say what if it's a joke about
being black because it could be a joke.
You know,
he really,
here's the problem and you can't really
make it up to anyone.
Right?
It's got to be like you're allowed to
say everything.
You're gonna not allowed to say
everything,
but how do you do a monetary number?
That's weird.
Well,
I mean like how do you make,
these are my doctor's bills,
my cycle,
my psychologist bills.
This is how much workup I've missed.
You could do it that way.
I think in this case in grant is not a
huge amount of money.
It's a lot,
but it's not like those Mcdonald's
settlements.
Right.
For comic though,
who's working for?
Sure.
Plus,
I'm sure has legal fees.
Right.
But what I was going to get at is did
the girl Heco first?
Yeah,
I see that.
That's what I don't know.
See if she did then fuck her.
Yeah.
Like yeah,
he probably shouldn't say mean shit
about her.
I've seen stories about a guy,
a comic going off on somebody,
so when the court of public opinion like
they get eviscerated because they went
off to hard on somebody but then people
would have to show.
But like none of this lady was heckling
everyone in the show.
Let's see what it says here in May of
2007.
I don't need to read her name.
And a girlfriend were at a club in
Vancouver,
have restaurant Vancouver restaurant
with a largely gay clientele.
When an open mic night hosted by Mr Earl
kicked off,
the two women decided to stay according
to the latest findings of the human
rights tribunal during the show.
Mrs purdy's girlfriend had ms dot
[inaudible] girlfriend had merely pecked
her on the cheek when Mr Earl told the
crowd.
Don't mind that inconsiderate dyke table
over there.
You know,
lesbians are always ruin it for
everybody.
Stop right there.
Go back up.
Let me read that.
I've seen that before.
All I did was this one,
their mom being fully making out and
then just dropping everyone.
Why else would we say don't mind that
inconsiderate.
You're ruining it for everyone.
I would imagine there's probably some
chatter.
Yeah,
probably that happened.
He went off to hard,
but we've all seen that.
What?
They don't want to admit that they did
that.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's always that.
It's always like,
I didn't do anything.
All he did was move my chair and it's
like,
no,
why would anyone throw you out when
you're a customer for doing nothing?
And it was just laughing.
Shut up.
There's a lot of different kinds of
lesbians.
Yeah,
there's like educated lesbians that are
into the art and then there's like the
bull dykey lesbians that are like more
thicker,
bigger boned,
right.
And then there's a lipstick,
lesbians,
they all Buddhism as line prompted boost
and ms dot parties table and then they
escalated the string of slurs and it's
like,
all right,
you don't like it,
you're singing artists,
get the fuck out.
Yeah,
I don't like this.
So leave.
Then it's okay.
You can just leave.
Really.
It's hard to watch your money back fine
and get your money back.
Or was it this where they just to really
pretty interesting women.
And one of them did kiss her friend on
the cheek lightly in the comic was
eating Dick on stage and he started
blaming these girls for the fact that
he's eating Dick onstage.
You ever seen that happen?
Absolutely.
So here's the day.
So we should be fair here.
Right?
So yeah.
So let's say it was that way.
So in that scenario they should get
their money back and leave.
You still can't stop a guy of artists
from fucking trying something.
Right?
Right.
You'd never get to know what the line is
unless you cross it and then you pull it
back a little bit,
so if you don't let a guy even try to
get to the line,
then you're hurting art in general.
This is what he said.
That's really rude.
You're not even lesbians.
No Guy will fuck you.
That's why you're with each other.
Okay.
I'm still on the side.
I'm smart.
I see myself saying that.
My darkest moments for sure depends
really.
We don't know.
We see like,
here's another problem.
That's a problem with when Kramer did
that stuff,
it was like,
oh yeah,
I get it.
I get the point of like,
I just want to hurt you now,
and that's not even what he was trying
to do.
Here's the thing and looking at it on
print here,
like,
yes,
it's so much different.
Much different.
Looking at it on print is so much
different.
We're missing.
It's just like,
first of all,
we don't know if that's exactly what he
said.
I mean,
it's just taking from a recording or
just from people's memory,
like how exactly do we know exactly what
he said and she says,
he said to call that discrimination,
but discrimination is if they wouldn't
let them in because there were less
young.
Jamie
says in the court case,
they used a witness testimony from junk
patrons that were there.
See,
you can't do that because I don't
remember guys joke sometimes and I'm a
fucking comedian.
They.
I doubt they remember exactly what he
said.
Especially if they're hammered.
Come on.
Everyone was bullying him.
He was an asshole.
It's like,
here's just going down.
Here's the thing.
Know from Mike or if comics are bad,
they will eventually stop.
They'll stop or they'll get better,
they'll get better,
but if you're hecklin he's not going to
get.
You're just fucking.
You're not supposed to do that.
And when you do do that,
you open the door to chaos.
Also.
I've had stuff where it's like,
I'm going to take it down one road and
then I'll,
I'll take it clear in the.
Don't worry if you just be quiet and
listen the whole time.
You'll see where I'm going with this and
you'll be fine,
but if you stop me in the middle,
it's going to make it seem really bad
what I said exactly.
So exactly.
If if you get interrupted,
you're just going to look bad and it's a
long second.
Make someone pay money off of doing the
art badly.
Exactly.
Except for when I'm not even saying it
was bad.
He might have fucking gotten other
people laughing at him.
Yeah.
I don't know what happened.
I don't.
So it's so hard,
but I think the monetary aspect of it.
A monetary judgment like come on
$15,000.
Like what really happened there?
Until you can define what really
happened.
Yeah.
It sounds so crazy.
She did just come up with a number.
15,000.
Pay The money.
Give money to people.
You have to give them money to leave to
get mad at you.
Yeah.
Can you say shit to people on the
street?
Can you like call someone a Dick on the
story?
Here's the thing,
if you get sued for that,
what is it about like like gay slurs?
Is that what it was?
What it was that it was a gay thing
because like what if he just
concentrated on other aspects of her?
Yeah,
exactly what it was like.
You can't get a better girlfriend
because you're too empty inside.
Like really want to hurt her in a
different way.
That nothing to do with it.
Yeah.
People wouldn't be as mad.
That was kind of bullshit.
It's not about the hurting.
It's about the how he's hurting.
Yeah.
He's hurting her by saying that he
can't.
She can't get men to fucker.
That's why she's a lesbian.
She's not even a real lesbian.
He's trying to hurt her there because
it's like,
well,
it's like why you listen to.
A funny thing to say.
That's what a comic would say.
He has to try.
Yeah.
Dissertation on
Lesbian Rights.
He's also add living,
and again,
we're not taking this guy side because
we don't know what happened.
I don't know.
I mean who knows?
He might have been a dick and then is it
up to the rest of the audience that
aside,
how's Nikki?
She was.
Or was it just like,
no,
I felt hurt so I get the money.
I.
It's just like,
it's an art form.
You can't stop anyone from doing or
saying anything.
That's why you allowed to smoke on stage
here because like,
well it's part of the stage.
Just like our pal smoke four cigarettes
the other night in a 20 minutes set.
Once I saw might have another one.
I was like,
yeah,
it was hilarious.
What does it say here?
In addition to Mr earls $15,000 penalty,
the restaurant was also ordered to pay
$70,000 since he was,
had a bar tab.
He was illegally an employee.
Oh my God.
So because the comedian had a small bar
tab to host the event,
the comedian was legally an employee.
Oh man,
that's sad.
It's Earl Lloyd.
The tribunal,
the tribunal.
What is the.
What rights do they have?
Nordic gods,
Greek and fucking thor comes down and
slams the hammer at the end of the
decision.
So stupid looking ms.party.
So that Mr the guy,
the comedian,
that host of the show,
we try to say that the lady played a
vital and highly dramatic role,
utterly disrupting a performance by
unpaid volunteers.
Comedy clubs like no other places.
The quintessential element that
distinguishes them from vapid mainstream
media is the fearless pursuit of free
speech.
Let's listen to this though too.
Played a vital and highly dramatic role
in utterly disrupting or performance by
unpaid volunteers from Mike can go on
and you guys are for that sentence.
When he finished that sentence and he
hit that period,
the judge should have said this over
here when you.
When you get out of here.
This is over.
Oh,
she was messing you guys up.
Well,
I just,
I'm on his side.
Just by the way he spells things spelled
things out like his,
his sentencing project and the judge's
words.
The comic was not giving a comedy
performance when he launched into his
tirade of ugly words directly at Ms Dot
Party.
But you can see that there were jokes
there.
Yeah,
that's not true because it was funny,
but even if he doesn't land them,
it's like if you can see any committee,
you can get an expert to say,
Oh yeah,
here's where he was trying to get a
joke.
Here's what he's trying to get a laugh.
Well,
let's scroll back up to the thing that
he said to her because it's clearly a
joke and if,
if,
if it's the way for the water,
and by the way this is people doing a
lot of water,
throwing shit.
She threw water at him twice instead of
telling them,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
She threw water at him.
Yeah.
Oh,
well that's just silly.
Come on.
Crazy lady.
Like,
what are we doing?
We kind of,
it wasn't enough.
We barely hitting each other.
We're going to slap slap fest for two
glasses of water through it.
Two glasses of water and he broke her
sunglasses and turn and he broke it.
Jesus Christ.
What?
What do they do?
And they're like,
chimps,
smack and trees.
I could see that somebody threw a glass
of water at me and the throat.
Another one,
and it was a girl,
so I couldn't hit her.
I'd be like,
well,
you can't just fucking.
I could see.
Wow,
I can see that.
Fuck.
If I would not as Mr Earl told that.
However,
even lesbians,
no guy will fuck you.
That's why you're with each other.
That's the joke.
Yeah.
Well,
it's clearly joke.
listen to his,
his point of view though,
he says the couple was passionately
kissing in the front and repeatedly
interrupting the set with obscenities
when Mr Earl tried to shut up the table
with the quip.
You're not even lesbians.
No Guy will fuck you.
That's why you're with each other just
thus kissing off the ugly escalation.
Well,
okay,
so that's the exact situation that's
happened a billion times that you've
seen.
People are being way too loud and
disruptive and they don't believe they
are.
They have no idea.
Well,
it's people who were talking about
before.
So this tribunal said,
okay,
if that happens and you're too harsh,
you're going to have to pay money that
you can't afford.
It's an open mic or is paying 15 grand.
Canada has legislated politeness.
That's how serious they take their
politeness up there.
They made laws where you have to be
polite.
Well,
in this situation,
clubs are going to start recording,
filming sets.
That's the only way they're going to be
out there.
I mean this,
this owner would have had it been.
That takes away the sort of stand up.
Comedy is counterculture and part of it
exists because like,
hey,
nobody's recording this.
This is all just existing right now in a
basement of some whole.
I agree and I think that's it.
Then you take away like,
hold on,
right?
I,
I agree with you.
I think it's a beautiful aspect of it,
but this poor fucking guy.
I mean if this is the landscape,
they're going to have to operate again.
He's the owner of the God damn club is
getting fucked over by an open mic or
hood.
So Hey,
he has no incentive.
Now.
This isn't just the,
the thought of any club,
any place,
have an open mic at their place.
Open mic nights are filled with crazy
people and people will become great
comedians.
Yes,
but the ratio very high
too crazy.
But even the ones that are going to
become great or terrible when they're at
the open mic.
Yes,
and they can make terrible decisions
fucking right.
And they might be one day,
20 years later,
your all time favorite comedian,
but right now they're clunking their way
through everything and spilling their
fucking drink and
just nobody does it right in the
beginning.
It's an ad Lib thing.
And when you're ad libbing like that,
like where there's people in the
audience that are disrupting this show,
if it's true from his perspective,
what he's saying,
well they're,
they're interrupting with his job and
his job is to talk and to be funny.
So now you've engaged in some sort of a
verbal warfare with a comedian who has a
microphone.
You can pay for that because they
couldn't see where the comedy will.
The fact that she threw drinks at home,
that's just sort of void out the whole
thing.
Like I guess was saying,
well she was already so disrupted that
she had a.
I don't know man.
I don't like talking about these things
if I wasn't there because we all see how
this,
how this could play out exactly like a
show.
You've been on that side of that.
So he is 100 percent.
So now,
right now what you're saying is,
hey,
open mic places don't,
don't start.
That's the worst part about it.
It's going to discourage the clubs from
taking a chance and putting on these
amateurs who they don't know.
These people owe you an open mic night,
folks.
Let me just put it in perspective.
We had a guy who dropped a bomb maybe 75
times at this place on sunset at this
recovery place of recovery place with
recovery place.
It was just where people hung out.
Oh,
and he did like a set thing?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was an open mic.
Was open mic and it was so
uncomfortable.
Whoa.
But then whatever he felt it too
probably won't do that again.
Or he will or he will cut it down about
10 n words or that's his point is just
trying to shock everyone.
Yeah,
that's fine.
He said it.
He just maybe doesn't know how goofy
sounds.
Some people don't know how goofy they
sound.
Yeah,
you gotta get a response from people
like if you're around and it's going to
shock what if that's what you're going
for is to offend.
That's what you're looking for.
That's the emotion you're trying to get
out of it audience,
and it's like we're going to legislate
and say that's not one you can get it
out of them or what if it's like you
think that that's going to be funny,
but it's not like you just suck it.
It just.
It's not working like you suck at this.
Kind of like diy as angry is one of the
funniest things ever on his fucking face
gets red and he starts getting mad.
He started screaming about how when he
was a kid,
bottled water,
he goes,
I used to drink puddle water.
He's fucking beat red in the face like
that.
That real anger.
That shit's hilarious because he's got
jokes and real anger,
but when you have like a manufactured
anger and you're trying to be edgy,
brands can see through them.
To me,
that's offensive.
It's offensive if you're not in the
moment for sure.
Like when Joey's talking about bottled
water,
he's in the moment.
It's,
it's,
it's a puddle of water.
We've.
We've all sort of figured this out in
our own way,
but when you're on stage and you're
locked in,
right?
You're either.
The audience is laughing hard,
everything's going great.
It feels like some kind of a mass
hypnosis in a way because you're
conducting them,
like pointed them at all.
Laugh.
Yeah,
both.
It's,
it's that,
but it's also like I feel like when I
watch were in the audience.
I watched bird the other day at the,
at the store,
the main room and then Chappelle the
other day in the EOA locked in to.
I loved it.
I loved it as a an audience member and I
was thinking like when they were doing
their jokes and I'm laughing,
I'm like going along with their thought
process and I'm as it's happening to me,
I'm recognizing this thing that it's
somehow or another they're thinking for
you like they're thinking for you and
you just on a ride with those things for
you,
your comic on stage.
No.
So when someone had some fake rant and
you're like,
oh,
stop.
Like if someone came over your house and
went,
the problem with the government is
programs on tv or programming you.
That's what they call them.
Programs.
You know,
if you were,
this guy was in your house,
you'd be like,
will you shut the fuck up?
C'Mon man.
If dns is in your house and he starts
talking to you about some shit you,
you just,
you have a free show you.
It's like a show with Ds.
We have shows with him whenever we hang
out.
Like he'll perform restaurant.
He was on the ride over here.
It was fun.
He's always on.
He's a live,
you know,
I just don't think it should be up to
anyone to decide what that line is of
right or wrong.
Nailed it or didn't nail it.
Yeah.
You just can't align is different than
your law.
Even the too soon kind of thing.
Like I heard somebody,
her Jeff Roth do a joke about something.
It was South Carolina but it was like a
year later,
but I remember people trying to do jokes
right there and people like no.
And so then jeff did it and it hit and
still got an oh,
like a year later and you're like,
oh,
but it's like,
oh well I want as far as an audience
member is the day of.
Yeah.
So we just,
we like different things.
I like spicier foods so it's fine.
My favorite example of people saying
something isn't funny that was fucking
hilarious.
Was already laying already laying got in
trouble for that twitter stuff because
he said,
he goes,
I was having sex with.
It's really,
I'm paraphrasing,
I was having sex.
It's really hot black girl.
And I was on top of her and she goes,
I can't breathe.
And I'm like,
let's not make this political.
I'll bring politics into the bedroom
politics.
People got up and screamed at him at the
cellar in New York and they stormed out
of there.
I mean,
this is like,
the guy attempted suicide too,
by the way.
Right?
Already,
wasn't it like a year before that,
like it wasn't like a long time.
Maybe
two years.
Right.
So he's just getting back to that,
that uh,
I can't breathe time.
It was like,
fuck,
fuck you Eric Gardner with those cops
about that.
And it's like,
oh yeah,
see me.
I felt,
I mean this,
the only way you would look at it and
say you can't make jokes about that is
if you feel like it's somehow racist
because if it was any other,
any other reason like you could totally
make a joke about.
Yeah.
Like you're not even listening to it,
right?
Just you're just going,
I think this is wrong.
I'm going to interrupt him.
Yell.
Yeah.
If you listen to what he's saying and
the joke like,
come on,
like that'd be like interrupting fucking
a.
it's not even a Joe Jonathan swift essay
because you're like,
wait,
are you saying we should kill kids?
They just appreciate chosen.
Yes,
exactly.
Let's get this guy to fuck off.
But the joke is not saying it's not
making fun of the guy who died in the
cops killing him.
The joke is making fun of everyone
talking about it.
Yes,
that's it.
It's just it.
The joke is him with a hot black girl
that needs smothering here because he's
fat.
She says,
I can't breathe.
I mean,
that's a fucking great joke.
It's a great joke and it's not mean.
Here's the joke.
The protests are affecting my life.
Last week I was having sex with a black
girl.
She yelled out,
I can't breathe.
I want to heat.
So he put it on twitter right at the end
of 2014.
So at the height of the right,
right,
right.
Oh well this was the punchline.
I think the black lives matter thing has
never been bigger,
so I'm thinking you'd say it the harder,
but I think it's bigger now than ever
before.
I don't think so at all.
I think it's kind of eating itself a
little when people going ah,
well,
like all the
comps.
Well also one of the guys that worked
for him was white,
uh,
real estate that kind of proved this guy
was white who one of the guys in black
lives matter.
It was white guys.
Apparently he's a white guy,
allegedly.
What the fuck do I know?
But the point is that one was
particularly agregious that incident
with that Eric Gardener Guy.
I got disgusted by that.
Oh yeah.
I was terrible because they all,
it was with cigarettes.
The guy was selling loose cigarettes.
He didn't do anything.
And that's the problem with that is that
comes from that.
It creates,
it's sorry,
it comes from a place of back.
I had to sell loose cigarettes to make a
living.
Not like he ain't Robin people.
He's selling loose cigarettes for a
fucking dollar,
a piece like the people who can't afford
a it.
That's not a guy who's wants to dream of
that as a job and a career.
So it's like,
all right,
they're poor people and you're saying we
have regulations with the government's
got to get paid so some guys are able to
push you around and they're like,
eh,
he had asthma,
but it's like,
why is he fucking big that violent,
this beat it.
Cops are not supposed to be revenue
collector's.
Yeah,
there's just not that stupid stupid for
the cop to be put in that position where
you're making them arrest people because
you have
a quota.
Like we have to figure out a way where
these people don't.
Don't get paid that way.
Like the idea that you have to have a
certain amount of crime every day in
order to keep your position as a cop.
That's insane.
Like what about a perfect world?
What would we employ?
A lot of great cops,
they become a member of the community
respected member because you don't have
any fucking crime,
so the cop doesn't be a problem anymore.
It's not like the old west.
Look at them as a thing here because the
sheriff's got to.
We'll comp.
You should look at comps.
W it would be ideal,
like in a perfect world.
Yeah.
All the people that were police officers
would be the coolest fucking people in
the world.
They just wanted everything to be cool.
Everything to stay calm and in the best
case scenario,
you live in a world where like we were
talking about how little violence there
is,
imagines that got way better.
Imagine if like the Douche douchebag
factor got reduced dramatically.
What?
For whatever way,
in whatever way,
imagine,
imagine how wonderful it would be.
The world would be perfect.
We wouldn't have.
We wouldn't have this fear that people
constantly have of getting their home
broken into getting their ass kicked or
getting in a fight or getting this.
We're getting that.
All of it could go away,
but
you can't just fucking choke a guy for
cigarettes.
You can't do that,
you just can't do it the way they slam
people's faces into that Shit meant what
is it?
Because it's written down somewhere.
What?
It's.
There's some,
some one decided there's a swath of land
and you've got a market cross it.
Some people sneak over,
they don't have good paperworks.
I don't get a good education or you
know,
this guy's life was like,
I don't know if he was an immigrant.
I'm making up an immigrant story,
but there's so many people that do so
many different things in this world
because they're trying to get by and the
idea that someone would tackle you and
choke you just because you're selling
loose cigarettes.
Like for worse,
a ticketable offense if.
How about if he's selling stolen
cigarettes that he broke into a building
that's one thing.
Well,
this guy,
so they told,
they told that,
uh,
whatever,
the head cop there was like,
no more choke holds.
And so he did it anyway.
Yeah,
he had a PPO,
but.
So he'll have to choke a guy like that
and their defense.
But here's the thing,
that choke shouldn't kill you.
You certainly do.
If it's a fight,
it wasn't a fight.
Exactly in that situation and if he's
defending himself,
I'm saying the only time you would have
to use a chokehold against a person is
that if that person is somehow right.
So okay,
let me just dragging.
The guy told them to stop using short
codes and use it anyway.
Now you have to.
If you want to take the gun to the
ground.
Yeah,
but he said the head cop was like,
guys,
no more of this before this.
He was anyway.
So if I went and choke somebody and he
died and I can say,
well,
he just had had asthma.
What trouble would I be in big time?
Manslaughter.
Manslaughter,
sure.
Yeah.
Couldn't I couldn't use the excuse.
So it depends.
Depends on what evidence the guy could
be like in this situation.
So let's look at this situation because
in this situation that guy was totally
passive.
He didn't do anything wrong.
It was ugly.
The way they grabbed him.
But I'm.
What I'm saying is if you want to
control a guy who's that big once,
once it's a physical altercation,
don't wait until he starts punching you
or biting you before he choked him.
You choke them quick.
That's just what you do and I don't.
I'm not condoning it in any way,
shape or form.
I think it was a terrible,
terrible miscarriage of of like what's
ethically right,
what's ethically right.
It's not that the people with guns that
are employed by the state come after you
and drag you to the ground because
they're not getting their tax money from
you,
which is all this loose cigarette thing.
And what if the store owner did the
exact same thing?
Well,
what if what you were saying you did,
you would have to have a reason to do
it.
I mean it would have some.
It looks like the same reason the cut
was like,
Hey,
I don't want you here.
I sell cigarettes in here.
I think I was like,
I'm just trying to do.
And then he just ran up on them,
choked him,
and then he has asthma made him die.
It depends on how it escalates,
you know,
if you just attacked him,
I would say.
Yeah man,
you just assaulted him for no reason.
Like what if,
what if he told you to fuck off and then
try to sucker punch you and you had to
duck under his punch.
He didn't do this though.
Exactly.
He didn't.
So then it would be a different story.
So in this situation,
I mean this wasn't like the store owner
didn't do shit.
They called the cops,
the cops,
but it was about a fight because that
guy had,
he had,
there's been a fight before.
That's why the cops had showed up.
So they showed up.
All geared up.
Yeah.
They showed up geared up because there
was an incident and I think this guy
might've even called it in.
The guy who they wound up killing.
Oh No.
Yeah.
I don't know exactly what happened,
but this dude just happened to be there
when it went down.
I might be wrong about him calling it
in,
but he was just there and so they,
they come looking for this fight.
The fight wasn't there and then they
started going after the result of this
cop.
What's happened to them?
I don't know,
man.
I don't want to single the cop out.
I don't even want to mention his name.
The other thing is you get offers in
trouble.
I'm sure he was a cop,
right?
I was just looking right now,
two days ago,
accomplished.
Charged in this incident in the Eric
Garner,
a woman,
so it's not the one that put him in a
choke hold.
I mean we could be one of the ones
that's in charge of the people that did
it.
So I'm looking right now though.
That's what happens when you're a
leader,
right?
You.
That's again,
like the club owner and the open miker
magic.
If you're a sergeant and you're a rookie
out there,
choke some guy to death and you get in
trouble and you get kicked off the
force,
you lose your cushy job.
She's charged right now with failure to
supervise an internal charge him that
God would failure to supervise.
How the fuck is she supposed to
supervise?
Like these guys choking this guy on the
street?
Who would it?
What is she supposed to do?
It's like the losses on the coach is
your forearm under his chin?
Yes or no?
Stop.
Let me check your technique.
What is she supposed to?
New York and there was cops.
I remember passing by this cops talking
to each other.
One was gone and that's not a choke to
fucking show.
Not a choke.
Let me put you in.
Got It.
And in a.
In a hold on his neck.
Let me put you in it.
No,
thanks.
I'll choke the shit out of somebody.
Anybody tells me that's not a chuck.
Let me hold you in like that.
Well,
what qualifications?
You have to be able to say what a choke
is.
Me?
Yeah.
Oh,
I've got a couple of things.
Would you definitely be called an
expert?
I said it on twitter.
I said as a martial arts expert,
I even said that it's a professional
martial arts expert.
I'll tell you very clearly.
That's a joke.
I will choke the fucking life out of you
with that.
If I have your head in between my arms,
forget me.
Okay.
How about Eddie Bravo?
Listen to me,
if Eddie Bravo has your neck and it's
trapped in between his arms,
you're going to sleep,
you're just going to sleep.
That's a choke.
If he's got your neck like they had eric
gardener,
you're going to sleep.
If Jake she look at this.
Come on man.
That guy has his finger tucked under his
wrist,
the hand in the back.
He's just got a shitty choke.
He's got it.
Doesn't have the proper technique for
sure.
Right,
and the other guys hold.
He's.
He's definitely underneath the guy's
Chin though,
but this is just a freeze frame.
That might've been like a brief
millisecond of of struggle,
you know,
where he was pushing down with his left
arm and up with is right.
Because if you look at his right arm in
this position,
that right arm is just an under hook.
That's not putting any pressure on his
neck.
The only thing that's putting pressure
on the neck is the left arm.
It's under the chin,
but there's definitely some space.
There's definitely some space between
you because it's not under his chin.
You see where his chin is like,
look at.
Make it bigger,
real quick,
make it bigger.
But this is just one picture.
If you see where his chin,
his back,
what happened?
Go into your twitter.
How dare you?
Oh um,
but I saw an image where they were like
on the ground.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I saw a different image.
There it is.
See that's.
Oh,
for sure.
That's always got under the neck.
That's a fucking 100 percent choke.
Choke you to death with one arm like
that.
If you let me,
if you let me get under your Chin like
that.
Like this guy's letting them.
He's not,
he's not resisting.
He's being what I mean he's letting him
and he's in a position where you can't
do anything about it,
I should say.
Even if it doesn't halt,
let's say nothing happened to him.
You know,
he's not,
he's not defending it,
you know,
he's not defending it.
It's 100 percent of that guys might,
the left guy,
he's an aside choke position.
So he's pushing down with his left
shoulder as well as pulling up with his
left hand.
And if he puts his left hand on his,
on the Guy Eric Gardener shoulder,
he uses that as leverage like guys took.
Luke rockhold tapped out.
Michael Bisping with one arm.
Get the okay from the mount position.
That's a powerful move.
Mean this.
It's not exactly this move here,
but it's very similar in regards to how
much pressure you can put down what your
shoulder and how much you can pull up
with your,
with your arm.
That's a fucking choke.
Choked the shit out of you.
With that.
Somebody gets you into like Marcello
Garcia.
How about Jocko?
Ray?
Chakra ray gets a hold of you like that.
Yeah,
that's a fucking choke.
You're going to go to sleep and he's not
the best in the world.
Okay?
Don't get me wrong.
It's
not like the perfect choke.
The perfect joke is,
you know like a Marcello Garcia rear
naked choke where the technique is just
so laser sharp.
There's a laser.
Laser's might not even be sharp.
Like in Star Wars,
they're not sharp.
Really need to watch this guy die.
They're fucking with them.
Will tell you that.
He's like,
I didn't sell anything.
He didn't even have loose cigarettes on
them when they arrested him.
Did you know that?
No.
Nope.
Didn't have them.
You can tell you Sydney
forcibly trying to lock somebody up for
breaking up a fight.
So yeah,
he broke up a fight.
The
world needs is a mediator.
What do you mean stop?
Let's press a button on our APP.
We have a life mediator show up who's
like a really cool dude like the rock.
Like I feel like you're the rock could
have kept that guy alive.
He got there in between the coupler
boys,
boys relaxed here.
Let's talk this through.
Let's be rational.
Man will regret it in the morning.
He'd only have like some motivational
shit.
Maybe take them to the gym.
Everybody does some squats.
There's had a show.
I think we all did.
I think it was where the guy was getting
kicked out and they were like,
he wouldn't leave.
So they call the cops and like you gotta
get Outta here.
They're gonna arrest.
You just leave.
Oh yeah.
That video made a video of remember.
Oh,
I don't really.
Yeah,
there was a video of it.
It's not going to rape you.
You're small.
They're going to rape.
You just go.
So you don't get raped in prison.
You have to go.
I'm pretty sure red band got a video of
it.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I think he got rid of a video of it and
then maybe a video of the guy getting
arrested later.
Oh yeah.
He wouldn't go.
He was settled in.
Yeah.
You never know man.
God damage if your life is good.
Life is good.
But I needed a tank show already landed.
What did he talk about?
He talked about.
He told two stories.
So one's gone.
Just what's going on.
TV They talked about,
um,
when he was on mad TV doing a bunch of
blood while they was supposed to be
working.
And
this is the only life where you can talk
about things like that and just casually
and it seems funny.
Yeah.
Whereas if he was an insurance salesman
and he was talking to the people,
it is counting on talking about your
cocaine by the way.
New Episodes,
February 23rd on comedy central.
Oh,
season two is he,
it season this season dose
should say that year.
Um,
but I,
I like what you're doing.
Like overall I like what you're doing
with your life.
I like how you go on these nutty trips.
You just take a month and just go
somewhere.
He went to Thailand for awhile like you
do and what it's like you talk to your
average stoner who,
uh,
is a brokester and it's just barely
getting by man.
If I had fucking money note I do,
Dude.
I wouldn't even be worried about shit
man.
I just fucking leave my phone behind.
I go to Thailand for a month.
I don't give a fuck.
I tell my agents suck my dick.
I'll be back in 30 days until then.
Dale.
We have meetings but we have.
Fuck you.
I'm going to Thailand.
Just bring your laptop.
Fuck you.
So you just decided,
you just decided I had to go to Atlanta
first issue some to Thailand.
So I mailed my phone back to my home.
Yeah.
Do the one gun.
The plant?
Yeah.
I don't want that.
That's how you're supposed to do it.
Yeah,
it was so much fun.
Now you're doing it exactly the right
way.
Find some shit in a new country.
Some crazy noodles.
Yeah.
Experienced some weirdness.
They sell so much Viagra on the streets
of Bangkok.
Thank God is everywhere.
They just look at you.
I looked back up,
I got.
First of all,
this is like Viagra.
It's such clearly a knockoff.
Does it work?
I don't know.
I wasn't going to try it because they
weren't discounted to like a dollar a
pill.
There was like,
there were like half as much as they
would have cost and like a store here
and that was offensive to you.
Look at your face.
You're like,
excuse me,
we're a third world country.
My money.
There are children working right now and
it's 3:00 AM and that's guys six.
And He tried to sell me shit.
So I think the places should reflect
that.
Yeah.
You don't need a lot of money to get by
and Thailand,
right?
Oh No.
Once you're there,
you're good.
And it's doing everything safe.
Thailand's a little more dangerous.
China,
super safe.
Thailand you can get.
You can get fucked with a little bit,
but it's relatively safe.
It ain't like any worse than here.
Really.
The only thing I gotta worry about a
little bit.
It's cops more.
Oh really?
Thailand?
Yeah.
They probably know more.
Tie you up maybe,
but yeah,
I walked around the streets and shit.
Even the small players in the big
places.
Yeah.
I didn't really feel any danger.
Did you go to Moitai fights?
I went to Thai kickboxing fights.
Yeah.
Our hair and our hair.
All right.
They just play this fucking thing the
whole time.
Yeah.
It's annoying sound and they each have a
dance of their own.
Like Sensei,
they have to do this special dance.
Have their own Dojo.
Well,
it's called.
I think it's called the white crew.
I think that's how they.
How they spell it wrong.
Yeah,
it's pretty dope.
They have.
Okay,
so you just walked down this like you
explain what that is.
What the whole.
The whole little dance because people
are like,
what the fuck are they talking about?
They have to do this.
They introduced each person and then as
they're both in there.
I think that you together
maybe one at a time,
I'm not really sure.
They just do this act out dance where
they just sort of like kick a knee up
and then do like a fake clench
kick and stuff,
but just by themselves,
not at anybody.
And then they do that for a while.
They go all the way down to like one
knee,
but
at the same time,
these are the hardcore guys.
They're doing a lot more of these
matches.
You see.
See this guy's wraps on their hands.
They're going to fight bare knuckle.
See,
this is a,
it's not totally bare knuckle.
You have wraps,
but they're not going to wear gloves and
there's quite a few fights they're
taking place where guys are fighting
like this.
Now.
I'm wondering if it's an impact of a mma
be more popular.
Oh really?
Yeah,
because once I saw how these boxing
gloves on because this guy following
instagram sand shy,
he's a bad motherfucker and he um,
he just fought the other night with
those gloves on were wraps rather no
gloves.
And I was like,
wow,
he's doing those fights like the top,
some of the top Thai guys are doing
these fights wrapped around their head.
It's just sort of like,
this is all ceremonial right now.
Well it's so,
it's not just a spin things with their
hands.
No,
it's also a warmup.
See when you watch what he's doing here,
when he bends his knee down and picks
his foot up,
he's stretching his hips,
he's stretching.
I'm like all the muscles around his
upper leg.
It's to make it more loose for kicking
a.
So He's loosening up.
See all the power in your kick comes
from weight,
but it comes from your hips.
A lot of it is the swinging of the hips
and the engaging of the hips when you
throw kicks.
So what he's doing is like,
it's conducive to warming up that area
where you were going to light someone's
legs up.
They're both doing it.
See how they're doing it.
It's a warmup to warm up for their own
rights.
But it's also spiritual.
You have to have these,
uh,
so you're walking down the street and
you see an alley.
And you just go down the alley and
there's just a ring in the middle of it,
maybe a pool table and like for like
makeshift bars around it,
there's like,
like,
like it almost looks like a lemonade
stand at the Rose Bowl,
swap meet,
you know,
and then you just get booze.
Some people come around taking bets,
like who do you want?
Why?
Then if you pick the right guy,
you can get whatever you want and
they'll just pay it off.
It is a beautiful art.
Yeah.
I love Moitai.
It's beautiful.
But it seemed like that he was doing one
legged squats.
And when you're doing that,
you're just trying to catch them up.
Yeah.
He's just trying to warm up his hips and
they're right next to each other too.
And they're about to beat the fuck out
of each other.
It's so weird.
They're all real respectful.
Yeah.
I didn't see any.
So I went to a couple of different ones
that he's weird promoters.
This is just back alley things.
Then they just get like 50 people to
show up.
Well they,
they,
they are the same way though.
Even when they're world champions,
really,
really interesting.
Yeah.
I've seen world championship fights with
the two fighters get,
but I've also seen animosity.
I watched his fight in La were bookout
was fighting this guy and blue cow,
I think his name was par permit.
It's like their name,
the part of their name is what their gym
that they're fighting out of,
but I think is his actual name is bull
cow.
I think I.
I'm not sure either way.
He's a bad motherfucker like a world
champion.
World class tie fighter.
And he fought this dude who was really
disrespectful to him.
So he did this like very violent and
aggressive dance towards him.
Really?
Yeah.
It was very different.
It's very different than I'd ever seen
before.
Or He'd like launched arrows,
Adam and shit and like had all this
choreographed,
but it was like directed towards this
guy.
Then they fought and he fucked him up.
He lit him up.
He shut the arrows out of and also
fucked them up.
Well,
he fake shot the arrows during his
dance,
but when they thought he fucked up,
he was like,
I felt the trash he.
Well blue cows on.
He's on a very high level as a tie
fighter and there's a lot of fighters
who were maybe aggressive and athletic
and they hit really hard and they
overestimate their ability and they just
think they're a bad motherfucker.
They've knocked a bunch of guys out cow,
they're going to knock this mother
fucker out too.
Like people have this idea in their
head,
but you get in there with that guy and
you realize like,
oh,
okay,
this.
I can't even hit him and he's.
Every time I move he's killing my legs.
Every time I come close to him,
his knee is getting burned into my rib
cage.
He's elbowing me in the head on the
brake and then smiling at me and doing
it all over again.
He's going to keep doing it.
Your body's gonna start breaking down
and that's what happened.
He just started beating the fuck out of
this dude.
Like those guys were getting a little
aggressive there.
Yeah,
it was.
He got in the way of,
this is what lasts way longer than
anything I saw.
These guys love each other.
I think.
I think they're gonna start making out.
I think Jamie just tricked us into
watching some gay porn that's gonna
start off.
That's why I didn't have gloves on each
other with those things.
So,
um,
but yeah,
like I saw probably 10 fights the first
time.
And then in Chiang Mai I probably saw
another.
I saw another probably seven,
eight fights.
What was the fight where you and Duncan
were in the crowd at the UFC and you
timed it perfectly.
Don't know.
Fighting Nate Marquardt and Brad Tavarez
Powell from memory.
I remember that.
My wife was telling me some shit
yesterday.
I'm like,
you never said that.
Meanwhile she totally talked for like 10
minutes about it.
Really put nate Marquardt versus breadth
devops in the memory banks.
There's this,
that's it.
Nate Marquardt,
Brad Tavarez,
and then we're sending that.
They get close and when the camera came
to them they made out like a frosted
dying,
dying dare you.
How dare you.
So we're starting to throw it.
We started throwing a Illuminati signs
up for Illuminati side.
We made a big one with my whole forearm
and his forearm and his both giant
triangles and then he goes at some point
in buckets like we kept taking it up a
notch at some point that just leads to
me and he goes,
you know,
we got a kiss right
mother
fucker
here.
Right?
So I'm watching a fight and Duncan
staring at the monitor the whole time,
just staring,
waiting for it to come on us.
And then at some point she goes,
now I just had to turn and start making
out and we got to be careful about that
folks,
but get me in trouble.
Oh,
I know the.
He didn't even care.
They thought it was funny to interrupt
me.
The next day is an animal.
He doesn't give a fuck.
I didn't know.
Met Me.
He goes,
you to acquit the social media stars.
Morning,
get in a bad thing.
It's funny you didn't do anything wrong,
but Dana is a regular person for having
a guy who's the president of,
Oh my God,
so stupid.
We're children.
We're at 40 Ortiz.
Fuck is wrong with me.
Other people,
he thinks legit thing that he's in the
Illuminati
sign worshiper because I went to that a
performance that he did at that guy's
funeral or a funeral funeral.
This is where my mind was already out of
the wedding fund.
Remember someone's wedding?
It was one of the levators Anton Anton
Mulvey's.
We went to that doctor.
He performed it at one of his like for
birthday parties of the dead
grandfather.
Oh really?
How to show that wasn't there for that
one,
but dunking Hobo.
Yeah,
it was.
It was so bizarre.
It was just so strange that I ran into a
bunch of people I knew there to.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh,
you guys are quite the sickness.
So.
Well they weren't really satanist,
like thought of him was hired so day
Foley's wife at the time.
Oh yeah.
I was like,
Oh hey,
what's up?
She was there.
It was a bunch of people who didn't.
We run into some other comics there too.
I wasn't at the wedding.
He didn't go to their wedding.
It was just me and Duncan and joey.
Joey went.
He probably went to.
Yeah,
we were like,
what the fuck is this?
Wasn't some party,
wasn't necessarily.
It was a wedding.
It was like six.
I don't know.
Whatever.
I met a guy third was there too.
That's.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's cool.
Yeah,
I didn't get to meet him.
I like his music.
It's really crazy.
Yeah.
And he was the country roots to.
Oh deep.
He was awesome.
And that was wild and wonderful whites
of West Virginia.
It was a good movie.
Holy Bread.
Next.
Oh my God.
But he was great in it too,
you know,
I can.
He's like helping narrate it and talk to
the uh,
the JESCO,
the dancing outlaw.
Watch a fucking awesome,
awesome.
Strange people.
They run shit too.
Huh?
Well,
sort of.
I mean they're only getting arrested for
the boys.
They're the real duke.
The Duke Boys are supposed to be like
these heart of gold moonshiners don't
want to fuck their cousin.
I'm not buying it.
I would be like,
really?
Look at this bitch.
She's nobody's fucking daisy.
Okay.
She can't get a goddamn boyfriend.
She's running around because she likes
she us.
She likes cletus.
She could.
She make it more obvious that she's cut
the legs off or shorts.
You could just finger her swing.
She's there for you.
She's letting me know she's hacking in
shorts like no girl ever,
ever done that ever.
Even now it's like God damn.
And she was doing it when no one was
doing it and she was wearing a men's
shirts like she just got done.
Fucking touch a man's shirt on like your
shirt.
She could be wearing your shirt down to
the fifth button.
Tied off on the bottom.
Ted,
come on son.
She's got a man's shirt on.
Why is that super hot girl?
Have almost no man.
That ain't number one.
Bonus number two bolts here.
You.
You don't even know your history.
So we're the number two bolts,
right?
Right,
right.
That's him and it's been a while.
Tom Wolf Pac man,
that hair.
Those are the number two's no,
these are still people go god,
look at those shorts.
Christ.
She was hot pink.
This makes me nervous.
Just looking at her.
You can see their fucking junk in their
pants.
Yeah,
they're dicks was hard as rock.
Oh my God.
And they're not even related to her
because not only does she have camel toe
on that she's got of the beginning of
one.
Just the beginning of badge.
Outline everything.
You could see the slice.
Yeah.
They had grandma panties back then.
Oh,
guess who doesn't care me?
Are you a panties guy?
What do you mean when you like.
I like when girls with dogs don't like
granny panties.
I think my girlfriend,
nothing.
Say it.
Somebody got
constraining yourself.
So they were moonshiners with a heart of
gold but never got any pussy.
And they were beautiful man.
Beautiful Man.
And they're hot cousin.
It was a show where no one fucked.
It was the most ridiculous world.
That was way more ridiculous in the fact
that they were shooting with lightening
with a dynamite at the end of it.
And they didn't have guns because they
did time for fucking running moonshine.
But the man should let them do what they
do down here in Hazard County.
We got our own rules and that was
nobody.
Nobody fucked.
Yeah.
You think fucking boss hog would have
had a slew of hookers.
She should have all that show now in
reality like this is what it would be
like.
Well,
let's think about her.
She was the only hot girl in the show
ever.
Look who she should have two dudes,
one of the grossest women of all time.
That's his wife.
How dare you.
He would have been choosing a wonderful
woman in the greatest killer fucking or
he would have been fucking her uncle
Jesse would've fucked.
Everybody was fucked up.
Cletus scooter,
boss Hog definitely would've.
He would've had her on the payroll.
She'd been riding right next to him.
That cadillac with the bull horns and
the front of it,
but she came on to the other guy.
Oh,
he was always coming on as gay as fuck,
and he was comfortable it because Jesus
was strong in his life.
That's why cletus didn't want to admit
it.
That's now.
That's them.
Now.
Show me now.
Don't,
don't do it.
Don't do it to meet Jamie should kill
this thing.
You were watching television now.
Oh,
look at her sitting up.
Her legs were so hot.
Just ridiculously high watching just
watching TV now,
but here's what's crazy about that show.
It was.
I mean,
was there another girl on the show ever
besides like old ladies?
Maybe she had a rule and the contract.
She could be the only hot one,
like listen,
benches.
I don't think there was ever another
really.
I watched it.
If I was running the dukes of Hazzard,
okay.
This is why I'm not an executive
producer.
The dukes of hazzard.
I would say,
okay,
why do we only have one hot check?
You guys out of your fucking mind.
We need a Baywatch.
This motherfucker.
I know it turned into porn.
If you were running it through seasons,
they be like,
let's just say,
hey bob,
it's a comedy folks.
You should have more funny hot girls in
the background doing other shit.
Maybe run another alternative storylines
and you have a plot and a b plot.
This is the problem with how they would.
As soon as you get some fucking he now
you're like,
let's put some more hot women that
Sitcom.
No,
no,
no.
I'm trying to diversify.
I'm thinking of Hot Indian woman.
That's what I'm thinking,
really hot Indian woman,
you always,
you think you're going to get.
It's that close to happening and she
showed me the smuggling shipment of
Jello and two of them have to.
You have some sort of battle.
Let's just make sure that punches up
when we write this together.
Yeah,
you don't want to be white.
Everyone will be at chop.
We make fun of white men especially.
Let's punch up.
Okay.
It's important or somebody recommends me
in a,
in an island in Thailand,
said Eddie Bravo.
He takes Muay Thai class there.
Instead of the problem was going to
teach a seminar.
Coast time we.
He was going to teach us out.
He was like,
please tell Eddie Bravo.
Well,
what are you have messenger for?
Improper?
Why another motherfucker get on twitter
like everybody else?
Oh yeah,
come on
to the Internet.
How dare he try to use you?
How about just say hello man?
He told me what?
You have a task.
What am I a carrier pigeon.
You Fuck?
What am I a raven?
You want to tie something to my ankle?
I go back home and teach me how to like
get the fucking kickup on my scooter.
I was like,
how do you fucking.
He goes,
Ari Shapiro.
I'm like,
yeah.
Like,
hey,
how do you kick the scooter thing out?
And it goes here.
Let me show you until Eddie Bravo to
come out here.
That would actually be really hot.
If you had a like a girl who was like a
super hot girl who would carry a message
to you,
taped to her ankle and then became a
service like a mess,
a messenger.
How do you know how like,
um,
maybe like you would hire someone to be
a clown at a birthday party or someone
to show up at your dance,
a show up at your office rather and do a
dance for you on your birthday.
You know,
somebody's got you a dance.
Graham did have debt today.
Instead of that,
you have hot girls show up like ravens
with a note attached to their ankle and
they have to put their leg up on your
desk and untie the note and give it to
you in some weird
sorta semis job situation.
And you read this little scroll that
someone had written out like old timey
back go away,
but just kind of how you can you have a
immediate one of those wax seals at the
stamp,
like absolute broken?
Of course.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
A wax seal around her ankle.
Like just some maybe.
Maybe a little hot wax got honor.
Oh,
I love fail in this message.
That was the test.
I like it.
I like being a little.
Maybe not hurt me.
That would be a new service.
How much would you pay?
$5 extra.
Well,
what I'm thinking is probably more.
Let's just concentrate on ballers.
Let's just.
When we move into bel air and Beverly
Hills where all these fuckheads are
driving million dollar cars and we just
start running to the forum,
Miss Yoga Slavia fucking uprising in our
country.
Let's get crazy.
Let's say each message cost it costs a
thousand dollars.
Should deliver a message in Los Angeles
in that style and that style.
$1,000 plus tips.
But you've got to make sure that girls
don't become hookers.
He doesn't just become.
I know you've already done it.
I have 30,000 more if you'll come on
into my castle.
How long have you been working for this
agency?
You have so much harder than all the
other girls who ever listen.
You don't need this shit.
How?
Sit down.
I'll call them.
Have a drink with me.
Do you like music?
What kind of music you like?
How about r Kelly?
Real talk.
Real talk,
bitch.
I wish you would burn my motherfucking
clothes.
We'll talk
if you heard real talk.
I heard it a long time ago.
Maybe the greatest song.
Humanity's ever done a whole video
series.
Everything amazing.
Oh,
the trapped in the closet.
You're thinking of the traps and closet?
Yeah.
Traveling clause was pretty deep or a
real top was.
The other thing,
real talk was one song was one,
one song in one music video art Kelly,
so he went a little crazy too.
Then came back.
Keep.
You
didn't do anything,
man.
Nothing happened.
Having to compete on a girl like girls
like 14 r Kelly is 40 more chapters of
this isn't real.
No.
Oh my God.
That sounds like the onion.
R Kelly has 40 more chapters of trapped
in the closet planned.
He's amazing.
I hope it never dies.
Wow.
I really hope he lives forever.
He might be my favorite person.
We'll talk.
There's a specific kind of crazy that's
famous.
Crazy.
No one will ever tell you they'll be
this crazy.
Let's be honest.
It's also a black,
famous,
famous crazy.
Couldn't pull that off.
A white guy.
I can't wear a clock around your neck
and act like it's normal.
If you're black guys can pull off way
more extravagant,
you know,
like,
this isn't racist.
I'm just being.
I'm just being real with you.
People says the guy with the sumo sword
on his desk,
so when he gave it to my
fucking racist,
how dare you?
Misappropriate culture.
Oh my God,
you're a terrible person.
I always knew you were racist.
You hide behind the fact that you're a
Jew.
I'm so persecuted.
Let me be racist.
Get the camera.
Zoom.
Oh,
the fat guy says,
Oh
God,
you changed the game and Sumos you
might've just made sumo.
Amazing.
Made irrelevant again.
The most amazing thing ever.
Just watching guys go to war.
Okay,
how about that guys going to war?
Not Allowed to stamp through.
The body begins to come apart,
so guys would usually be covered with
scars.
All the fat will be pouring it.
Get sliced.
Open
shields.
No,
fuck them.
No.
The belly shield at least make it like
Dole swords.
No swords.
How about like,
okay,
what if you were playing like with
lightsabers,
right?
But the light sabers just shocked you.
Oh,
but like a heavy,
like heavy shock.
Yeah,
like a Taser,
right?
Like a Jason Ellis type shock.
Yeah.
Lightsabers.
Imagine if that was the sport.
Oh my God.
I might have just invented the perfect
sport.
By the way.
Jason Ellis run with this.
Yeah,
go for it dude.
For Real.
I'll give it to you.
Yeah,
go ahead.
I'll even help.
Do they have lightsaber tasers?
They should.
If they don't,
they're retarded dude.
If I was a girl and a rapist came at me
and I had a taser,
I'd be like,
Oh fuck.
But if I had a taser lightsaber I'd be
like,
you're probably not going to continue
with this,
but you're fucked.
You're going to get outta here.
Yeah.
Any one can touch you with something
like a lightsaber,
like they might be able to.
Well,
depends on who you are.
Obviously if you're Steven Seagal,
he'll figure it out.
He'd be able to block it,
flip you.
You never touch him with any part of.
You touched it shocks you.
Yeah.
You'd have to just touch their feet like
fake.
You're going logo high,
You're going high at all.
Any sort of block out.
It would be.
Well,
anybody who knows fencing for sure you
would fuck you up.
Like fencers would be the most dangerous
people ever on earth.
Well imagine if you had one.
It was small and you could press a
button like you do with a lightsaber.
A rod extends.
Yeah,
like a metal rod because they have those
things like those Bhutan's the press a
button and it becomes a steel Bhutanese
Rod.
Yeah.
Dude,
why we 12?
What's wrong with us grown men,
we pay taxes.
So you would press a button and it would
just become electrified.
Yeah,
that totally seems like it would be a
real thing.
Wow.
Yeah.
They probably have that in development,
right?
How did they not?
If they don't,
they do.
Now.
The Batman should have that.
Fuck.
You should have that.
Superman was still fucking him up.
That's why this movie stupid.
I don't care what anybody says.
Who supermoon who would burden moon.
Just going to put crypt to modal
overlays.
Bodie into superman is going.
Go and make the world spin backwards so
that Batman doesn't get the fucking
Kryptonite suit dummy to make the world
spin backwards.
Only has to do is stay like 100 feet
away from Batman.
He could find that when I got the
Kryptonite just keeps spinning
backwards.
So it was like a month ago.
He would just pick up cars and throw
them at Batman till he died to stop.
Well,
he's not trying to kill him because he's
all good,
but if he wanted to he could.
Yeah.
That's the idea.
Right?
Everybody's.
You don't get it,
bro.
Batman always wins.
Listen,
bitch.
I met an evil.
Listen Bitch.
Even if he's evil,
the other guy's bulletproof.
Shut the fuck up.
He's an alien.
Did.
Do you remember when we were saying
people just get angry right now?
You don't even fucking understand comic
books.
When I did an instagram post about that,
oh my God,
people were so mad at me.
Why are you taking the fear factor?
Go seriously?
Why are you taking me books?
Yeah,
that's right there.
We don't know about the subject that you
just said.
I don't know about.
I barely barely know something about
comic books almost for Star Wars.
All the superhero movies were exactly
the same.
Yeah.
They don't look good.
We got to pull power back.
We gotta you gotta check in.
We got to know a bunch of powers.
The kid gets mad.
Other superheroes,
like I'll help pull pulled over powers
back.
Superhero fight.
It was like it was.
It was more than one preview,
right in star wars was that same movie.
The last avengers felt really stale.
Really?
Yeah,
because I saw it right after the machine
or what is it?
X X,
x,
x market,
which was excellent.
If you haven't seen x Maki.
Now it's a movie about artificial
intelligence and it is beautiful.
It is a perfect movie.
I wouldn't change a thing about that
movie was so good.
The ending wasn't like boring and long.
No,
no,
no.
That movie was amazing.
That movie was like,
Whoa,
because the reality of these things have
this artificial intelligence is guide
created was fucking feasible.
Really?
Yeah.
It was good.
It's really good though.
The dramas good.
The whole thing is good.
It's just so good and then after that I
went to see the vendors.
I was like,
this is so stupid.
I'm like,
this movie is so dumb.
It's just like I'm watching the Dukes of
hazzard take place with superheroes.
It's just was like.
It didn't mean anything.
Yeah.
Like X,
Mokena.
Everything meant something like the.
These people,
their interactions,
the other interactions felt we'll the.
There's some real palpable tension.
There's a real danger that they're being
played by these artificial creatures
that they've created that look exactly
like people.
It's good,
man.
It's good.
That's why star wars to me,
it was like,
ah,
whatever.
I Love Star Wars.
It was just like a b minus fun movie.
A plus a plus.
Not No real.
There's five stars.
I'll 10 times.
I loved it.
I did love it man.
I have,
I think almost exact opposite.
Tastes in movies.
A lot of music to you,
like a Sucky,
sucky selection of music.
You like the chip rock that I like
about it?
No,
no.
I like a little Noli.
She's got a beautiful voice.
Hey,
when I mentioned to read and you were
like,
hey,
who's the girl you were talking about?
Dude,
I picked up Eddie Bravo once and this
girl that he was dating way back in the
day and I had Cheryl crow playing in my
truck.
Uh,
and uh,
she's like,
why are you playing this if it makes you
upset?
I'm like,
this is mine.
This is mine.
She goes,
no,
it's not.
I go,
yeah,
it's a CD.
I got it.
The CD.
It's like,
no,
you do not listen to this music.
I'm like,
but I do.
So I don't know where we're going with
this.
Never spoke to her again.
How rude.
Rude.
Eddie Bravo.
Bringing these barbarians around.
Yeah.
You can't like chuck rock.
Otherwise there's some kind of a pussy.
Yeah,
it's weird.
I don't care.
I used to have my cds a alphabetized and
I would have them separated by cic
singers and male singers.
Have you ever heard of Grace Potter and
the nocturnals heard of them?
Haven't listened to that girl's got.
Oh boy.
So you know about Alabama shakes,
right?
No.
Oh,
well let's,
let's kiss one another.
There is so much bigger,
but yeah,
that's great.
Spotter.
Yeah,
they're pretty big now.
I think she's pretty big too.
We don't know dude.
We're out of the loop.
I know.
Alabama shakes.
You've heard it.
She didn't even have a phone.
You got some fucking 1980 Morris code
thing in your pocket.
I didn't even get.
It doesn't even vibrate when I get a
text.
It's in my phone if my pocket.
I don't even know if people texted me
and then I was like,
where are you?
And it isn't like,
oh,
I don't know.
It was walking.
Oh God.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
I got to only vibrate when it rings and
that's it.
Yeah.
I wouldn't only notification.
I went to a clusterfuck when my phone
upgraded and went from text messaging to
sending messages and then I turned the I
message off,
but then people were still sending me
ims juice that was getting them on my
computer,
but I wasn't getting them on my phone.
I'm like,
this is so stupid.
Like this system is so goofy.
Like how do you opt out of this?
How do you just.
I want everything in one place.
I don't need it going every.
I don't need to be getting phone calls
on my fucking computer when I'm.
When I put my phone over there,
I want to be able to get like the voice
mails later.
I don't want to see it on my computer
when I'm working,
so what do I have to do now?
I have to disable this and I've got.
Why is this set there by default?
Why is my phone making my computer ring
by the fuck?
Can I get some shit done?
God dammit.
Ari Shaffir.
It's always infringing.
It's always infringing in your day.
Ken Did the ball.
Go check twitter.
It's been four minutes.
Listen,
what if there's no response to ball?
He'll resistances,
few tile independence,
which is my real thing.
I think it's getting better,
but I don't think we've developed an
etiquette around phones yet.
You say that until you have four legs.
Every girl wants
to get that for less.
Girls don't even know why.
Something about them for legs just looks
up.
It didn't get way easier.
Jim.
I'll just say what about,
uh,
the twitter news of the weekend where
they might be changing some free
spirits,
free speech,
stuff that pulled away verification
from.
Well,
they pull away Milo Yiannopoulos
verification for bold.
Is Verification Away why they said that?
Well,
they don't say exactly violation of
terms of service.
So now he's no a verified.
Exactly.
But he's still allowed to post.
So there's some posts are saying if it's
offensive or the,
your account,
right?
Well they did not see.
He's not being any more like here's a
problem with that guy and it's not a bad
problem.
He's funny and a lot of what he's doing
is theater like.
And if he gets you riled up,
especially if he has a point.
And I think he has a point with a lot of
things he's picking on,
you know,
he's not dumb.
He's very smart and so he's getting
people riled up like a professional
troll.
It was also a very bright guy who writes
some pretty good articles and I would
say really good art.
What is someone who writes for
Breitbart?
He's like,
he's hilarious.
He's a conservative writer.
He's a conservative,
I guess a blogger,
I guess we'd call them.
You wouldn't say he's a journalist.
He's more of a,
you know,
he writes editorials,
writes just pieces.
Right.
But he's also gay,
like gay as fuck and conservative and he
goes into debates with these feminists
and just crushes them with facts and
they can't attack him because he's gay.
He has the,
he has the sketch down card,
he's got this weird loophole and he
knows what the fuck he's talking about.
Yeah.
I mean I don't agree with them on some
things,
but he's a very bright guy.
So when he finds someone that he can
pick on,
especially like he's really into picking
out feminists and calling them out on
their hypocrisy and picking on people
that just an eight minute he'll,
he'll go across the board with anybody
if he thinks you're being ridiculous and
he makes a big deal out of it.
So then what people got mad at what he
was saying.
Well,
he'll say,
I don't know,
you know,
he'll say things to rile people up.
They'll say offensive things,
but guess what,
you block them.
I think it's,
I think it's enjoyable.
Like I would think it's fun.
Twitter becomes weird where it's like
you have a bunch of followers who follow
you.
You say something funny on the offensive
side instead of on the cute side,
um,
you'll get retweets if some cute side or
if it's A.
Yeah.
So now the retweets go to people who
don't follow you and they might not even
know who you are.
And then go like,
what the fuck is that supposed to mean?
Who's this guy,
you know?
And they don't see any context.
They don't say it's one out of 10 tweets
in a row about a subject.
Uh,
so then they see it.
Then they get mad and they flag
it,
and then the people don't know,
like,
I don't know.
It's been flagged 7,000 times.
I guess people are mad at this guy.
We got to band them.
Well,
yeah.
Especially as a terrible road to go down
if there's,
if you're doing a series of,
of show one,
it's like,
oh,
you're not even looking at the context.
Exactly.
Yeah,
that can definitely.
They took away his verify and not be
verified.
Here's what I'm saying.
They fucked up because now you have even
made him a martyr.
Like you'd go,
you're,
you're playing right into a spiderweb.
Why is twitter getting involved in any
level of celebrity?
Which he seems like he is.
If was a known writer,
then he's a known.
He's.
He was great on the podcast.
Really?
Yeah,
he's hilarious.
He's,
he's a nut.
He,
I,
you know,
like I said,
I don't agree with them about a lot of
things,
but I like what he's doing.
It makes me laugh.
Like he's.
What is the difference when he was doing
what he's doing and what a lot of like,
funny humorous journalists have done,
but what about this evidence?
You say something Ernest,
that I think is like offensively wrong
and anti free speech and it gets me
angry.
I don't try to get them banned from it.
Yeah.
I don't mind but I don't mind because it
hasn't effect my mind.
I just don't want to stop them from
saying it.
I mean it hasn't affected me on a
professional level and if it has,
it's my fault,
you know,
anything that I've ever been affected by
it.
Like if I made a mistake because it's
clearly been my fault,
I've made definitely some errors,
but I think there's a difference between
like I think what,
what
decisions for them to make them for you.
Well bothers.
You don't want to.
Getting back to that guy in Vancouver,
uh,
that had to pay 15 grand.
What bothers me about any,
any interaction between two people that
like one person said something rude or
whatever.
Who knows what exactly went down.
That money starts being a thing that's
thrown around because then the
government gets their piece too,
by the way.
Right.
So they're on the side of like,
sure,
you should be able to sue them.
They also get their piece because of the
trial,
like these court costs.
Everything has to get factored in.
I don't know exactly how it works in
Canada,
but if it was in the United States,
Mike Ward isn't serious.
He's,
he's had a lot of money in his own and
his own lawyer fees because he's
fighting it.
He has cash.
He's like a,
he's like a well known French Canadian
comic.
So he has this whole,
like French Canadian tour.
You can do.
Which one was he with?
Mike Ward is the one with um,
what you were talking about it earlier,
but the kid who had some diseases
and he made a joke about that.
Yeah.
Okay.
And it was a bit had but like he's got
to pay all his legal fees and try to win
this and he could pay the 80 grand the
sooner for.
But he's like,
then that sets such a terrible
precedent.
So we just in his own battle on free
speech saying,
I don't want to lose this for what it
means.
It's fucked.
I mean it's people like full qm have
said that joke.
That's bullshit.
Of course he should have got laughs.
A bunch of labs.
He said it enough times where was a is a
winning bit and his act.
Yeah.
And you can't decide that you can't
take.
Well obviously they can,
but you should be able to take money
away from people like that.
Yeah,
I mean you might want to say you don't
want to ever go to one of his shows
again.
I'm not going to chick fil a,
the guy who supports,
you know,
anti gay stuff.
Okay.
There you go.
That's how you speak with your own
dollar.
Exactly.
Let,
let the market decide.
No,
I think that's a,
that's the appropriate way to the
fucking directors.
That guy who did,
who did pan's labyrinth,
whammo dealt garbage now how dare you.
So then it's like,
once you realize that,
but it's like
he used to be cool,
but now it's like fucking awful.
And it's just talking.
He's gone sour,
so then it's like I just won't watch
them anymore,
but of course go make whatever you want
to make in.
Well,
I wouldn't say went sour.
I still like it stuff.
You'd like the hobbit that he wrote just
like that last movie.
You didn't like it.
The last movie he didn't like it.
It looked like it was an acting class
thing.
Was it?
It was just like there was no acting.
You the cabin thing or you think you are
main wounds.
I mean I was probably pretty high,
but God,
it was such terrible acting and no plot
and just like,
wait,
wait.
I'll show you some special effects and a
little.
Did you yell out?
Know what?
I did leave.
Did you?
I left quietly.
Wow.
Me and the girl I was looking for
eventually we were like.
It was like we both realized we were
both wanting to leave for about 25
minutes and then I was like,
hey,
let's just go here.
Maybe you just want to get your freak
on.
Do.
Do you like that movie,
that new movie made?
Did you really do you have.
I'm not even going to bring up the what
the American side because I'm afraid of
it because it's say,
but no boots.
Bring that up.
Let's bring that up.
Because I saw it.
So tell me you didn't like it.
It wasn't a good movie.
This is the thing.
No development.
Exactly.
I never get to like him,
so now he's having trouble sleeping.
Suddenly it's good.
Again,
whites is where it's a scene in their
subject matter is highly charged and
very,
very sensitive to people.
So anything that's thought of in
disrespect of Chris Kyle,
people automatically get up in arms for.
I completely understood talking about
his book and I'm like,
I don't know.
I didn't read any that I saw this
fucking awful movie.
I,
yeah,
I completely understand people's
position in respecting him as a guy who
kept people safe over there.
I understand where they're coming from.
His wife,
half the movie when he's in battles.
Very angry,
but I was going to say it's just not
well done.
No,
it's not well done.
It's not just not that well done.
I mean,
it's just my opinion.
I just felt like it was flat and this is
like,
here's a good comparison.
I,
I hate to beat a dead horse,
but I'm x Mokena Ipa,
watch x Maki now and watch that movie.
There's a way that it's shot.
There's a way the story's told that
story is a very compelling story.
It's kind of a crazy story.
That countdown was a good move.
That was like,
whoa.
Clipping and fucking yes.
Exacerbating the Chris Kyle counselor,
you know,
would've been fucking.
Ryan was great.
How about tell the truth about Chris
Kyle's life like in towards the end
where he was involved in that Jesse
Ventura thing,
which is really kind of crazy where he's
making up a story about a fight with
Jesse Ventura.
That never happened.
So Jesse Ventura sued him and won and
then after he won,
he,
he got Chris Kyle got killed and Jesse
Ventura got all these death threats
because you want to continue to it.
Well,
it wasn't that much of a year before he
died.
It was just some guy who's lying about
me.
Well,
I think you can be both.
Yeah.
This is where things get really
confusing.
Jackson rapes boys.
I don't think he did.
I think he just jerked off in front of
him and shit,
stuff like that.
Maybe he was raping them.
I just feel like that would have got
out.
Yeah,
maybe you're right.
I think it was just parties and like
maybe stroke,
but definitely inappropriate boners.
If he could get one.
He got one.
I mean during that time period.
I mean he's got to find time to jerk off
unless he's jerking off in the shower,
you know,
touching it.
These kids,
they're over the house all the time and
they're sitting in his lap and you know,
just blood.
They're sensitive tissue
side.
His fault or my fault.
He didn't.
I mean it's just love.
Everyone's so sensitive.
It's just love.
God.
Well,
could just be beautiful.
Cup of listening to Ben.
Exactly down.
Oh yeah.
Good Times.
I'm the one in the room with macaulay.
Anyway,
I got on that.
How do we go that?
We just,
I just went with it.
What we're talking about somebody that
you can be two things at once,
it doesn't mean he wasn't a hero.
Artists.
Those saved.
Yeah,
we'll think about what he did.
Right.
There was a great sniper saved American
citizens that were over there fighting
in the war against other people that
were fighting against American citizens.
The way.
Hold on,
sorry.
Sorry.
Draw your conclusion about who's right
or who's wrong.
Get that out of your head and he was
trying to protect his friends.
Right,
so whether or not you think that he
should be on this team or that team or
this team is bad and that team's good.
We'll put all that aside.
He kept a bunch of people live.
Those people came back.
Whether or not you think they should
come back,
whether or not you think that she'd ever
been in there in the first place.
He definitely helped countless.
I mean it's probably actually probably
if this movie is about the French sniper
or about sniper,
the world doesn't exist.
It's was not a good movie.
Yeah.
It's not a good movie he ever took was
like 2000 yards.
I don't remember the numbers anymore and
then,
and then he hurts.
So and so Mustafa was getting shocked
that long.
He's like,
it's possible I've shot that,
but that's the longest I've ever shot.
And then when he shoots him at the end,
it's twice as far as the longest shot
he's ever heard of it can't even see the
guy.
You just see a blur.
And he goes,
I know it's him.
It must be.
I have a feeling.
Yeah.
And then it goes,
Yup.
Got Them.
You can't even see them,
you know,
made the twice as long as any shot
that's ever been recorded without being
able to see it.
You just know you have you made it.
Yeah.
You need a spotting for 200 yards.
You know,
people look at as target that's 200
yards away spotting scope to see where
you're hitting on the target.
Cause like it's not that good to see how
the scope.
Like you're a rifle scope from 200
yards,
which is nothing.
So like two football fields.
It was just.
So here's,
here's the question though,
is it also a factor of you're telling a
real person's story with his little
variation from the truth as possible
over at an acceptable period of time,
a two hour movie or whatever it is.
It's fucking hard to do,
but they didn't do a good job of it.
They did a terrible job of it,
but it would've been incredibly
difficult to do even if it did a great
job.
And let's just back up a second.
I'm best actor.
Yeah,
that.
That's not real.
I mean,
come on.
He looked like he could tell what he was
doing lines where he was hit a rubber
baby and I knew that.
Forget to rubber baby,
but he's moving the rubber baby with his
fingers and thumb.
You can go fuck yourself.
Okay.
I'm not a kid.
What did you do on a magic trick that I
can see who and were going to stick this
into my hand and you're shoveling in
your wrist at the same time.
My thumbs coming apart,
bulging your shirt at the fucking Hanky.
Still sticking out a little bit what?
God.
Even in the beginning when he finds his,
his girlfriend and the other guy,
those are out there having that talk and
he's drinking a beer.
It's like,
dude,
come on.
You're not even a real person.
This is acting class.
I can see you doing lines,
but he's not a real person.
He's behaving in this incredible,
exemplary way.
Like a hero.
He's in practice.
He's a beautiful hero.
He's not perfect hero and we can't
believe he's gone.
I mean,
that's what he's a hero.
He's in a
fight with his girl and he stands up and
they're like,
you're just tell that the directors in
the background,
feel it more.
Not.
Feel it more.
Yeah.
Let this hit you.
You love America because it's happening
to you.
Feel it more.
What's the problem?
Whenever you try to dramatize anything,
you know that movie Fox catcher is a
clusterfuck of lies.
Really movie that's based on Mark
Schultz and David Schultz,
sort of Olympic wrestlers.
They were a very famous American Olympic
champion wrestlers.
They were both beasts and there was this
crazy guy named John Dupont and John
Dupont had a lot of money,
so like the dupont name and he was a
crazy man and he wanted to wrestle,
so he hired all these guys and built an
incredible world class training facility
and paid them and these guys were
struggling wrestlers.
They went down there and uh,
one of the guys,
Dave wound up getting murdered by dupont
and it was just crazy store and Steve
Carell played him in the movie,
but the movie,
although it was a good movie,
the reality was way off,
way off.
Like they changed the timeline of the
UFC.
They stayed,
they had to the UFC existing like way,
way before it did.
I'm less concerned with that than if
it's a movie then,
unless they say it's like a actual
biography.
Yeah.
I'm less concerned with that than,
than if a like narcos.
I'm like,
know some of this is based on truth.
Some of this,
just like they didn't know the
relationship with this guy in this
because they didn't have to fake that
historic data.
Did they figure because they're idiots?
What benefits of this plot?
It's somebodies thinks they're smarter
than everyone who's going to know the
truth,
which is the dumbest thing too,
to think.
You should never think if you're going
to talk about a subject like the UFC,
which to a person like you,
I know you're a fan and definitely into.
You know when it starts offensive as
fuck.
When you try to pretend it started a
different date.
Then when you watch him watch on
television,
watch big daddy goodrich fight,
but then when he fights in the movie,
he fights them.
White Russian guy.
Bullshit.
He fought big daddy goodrich.
Mark Schultz fought big daddy good.
Which I watched it.
He beat his ass.
He took him down at will and I remember
watching it going,
Jesus Christ,
this is what happens when you get elite
Olympic gold medalists,
world champion wrestlers.
Like I was thinking to myself,
who the fuck is going to keep that guy
off of them?
That could have been a world champion
for sure.
He nobody wanted to know.
He was in the UFC,
fought big daddy goodrich in the UFC,
but there was no money back then and he
had a Gig with a.
He was teaching wrestling at a college
and not paid more.
What was coach a wrestling coach?
Like a university gig.
I mean he's a really respected wrestler
and they didn't want him cage fighting,
so they told him like this is it,
like you have to make a decision.
So he had to go with the the obvious job
because there was no money in the UFC
back then is fucking really dangerous.
But they changed in the movie.
They had them fighting in some unknown
organization.
It wasn't the UFC and the guy was a
white Russian guy who was fighting like,
hold on,
let me ask you a question.
Could this be the reason they changed
it?
Because what the UFC means right now is
like this massive thing.
So they'd go,
well viewers,
if they saw this like,
yeah,
you have.
See that's really big.
I would give up UFC where you're like,
no,
you need to be in the place.
Back then,
this was just a rogue thing.
People just did it to mix.
You know what I mean?
I see what you want to have.
Cursing in deadwood.
It's like,
yeah,
they didn't have that then,
but you're not gonna understand the
cursing they actually had.
Did they have cursing back then?
They had like rapscallion and shit,
so he wouldn't hit as hard as it as an
scallion,
so they had to change the reality to
make it the feeling of the issue.
Imagine if you were doing a comedy show
in the wild west and someone tried to
heckle you,
fucking go to that guy.
What kind of damage you could do to them
with the cursing I have now rapscallion,
you're a cunt.
You fucking bitch.
Well,
you're anchored out of here.
Fuck boy.
Here.
You're angry and it's not even a real
person.
We're talking about.
It all worked up,
man.
Fucking pea pea shooter,
motherfucker.
She was Christ peter,
Rusty Stirrup,
cunt.
And then he brings you in front of the
tribunal and you have to give up three
pieces of gold.
Fucked up.
Three pieces of gold,
gold shift here.
What it's going to happen,
man.
Are we going to go bitcoin?
You think I've got to get Antonopoulos
back on.
It's been awhile.
I don't know.
Probably.
Tell me again.
I'll.
I'll believe them again.
By the time I come back here in two.
You don't know how to spend bitcoin.
How to spin it.
Spend it.
Hm.
That's a problem.
If you don't know how to spend your
money,
probably look into it,
but if you don't have this ancient
fucking phone,
you have to be plugged
into your laptop,
but some sort of Ethernet cable,
don't ya?
You got some 19 seventies laptop too.
Don't you fuck.
Come on.
Book pro.
That doesn't even have a USB port,
does it?
Which one doesn't have a USB port?
Do they have one that doesn't?
Don't have CD drives anymore?
No.
One of them doesn't even have a USB
port.
There's a real skinny one of the air.
No,
it's not even the air.
It's like it's not the air.
Google that shit son.
Don't have them.
I know that.
Yeah.
I pads don't have USB ports,
which was USB port.
USB is where you would plug things in,
you know like if you were trying to sync
your phone up to it or something like
that,
plug your phone by USB or if you want to
save something on a drive,
but they didn't have the USB Port to
port.
No,
it has a little battery thing.
Sticks to charge your phone.
You don't.
Don't fucking laptop.
Maybe can't handle it.
Maybe it can handle the power draw
because it's so thin,
like it only exists as something that
you can store things in the cloud,
which is where they're trying to snake.
I try to bring you.
Bless you.
Do you still accept.
Bless you even though you're not
religious anymore or did I just defend
your sensibility?
Did I trigger you in any way?
Hurt man.
I don't.
It's not a correct gender pronouns for
today.
I am a.
He today ain't going by he.
I go by he everyday.
I'm going to try z out for awhile.
Z,
h e e Dot.
What is that?
Is that a new one?
Gender neutral.
Gender neutral was kind of like shit
hit.
You'll be whoever you want.
Z,
H dot.
I'm just already.
Oh,
why does it have to be directly?
Why do you have to say,
Mr?
What do we formal ha my fucking checking
into a hotel position of words are
using.
It's like no one has to say that.
That's just what they've been saying.
I think they,
uh,
you need to be able to control what
people say.
I love that people like shit on some
sort of stand up and they go,
oh,
what is that all you can talk about it.
It's like,
that's not all they can talk about.
That's one little sentence in this whole
bit.
That's part of the whole special.
It's really not all they can talk about.
Yeah.
But if I'm going to make fun of it,
that's what I'm going to say.
I want to say that this is all you can
talk about,
bro.
You like drag me to hell too.
Huh?
Love me and read.
I went to see a up and we were so happy
and so Gora where like you fucked up.
She just dragged me down.
I finally saw it.
I'm like this movie,
whether it's a comedy.
Perfect.
You weren't high enough and you didn't
go see with me.
Come see you.
Me and Duncan would see.
Drag me to hell.
We would love it.
Love it.
We would have the best time you ever see
up.
Yes.
Cartoon.
Yeah.
I liked up up.
Was good.
That's good.
It's interesting,
but it was sad.
It was that the first 10 minutes are
beautiful.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
You saw what won best comedy last night
at the Golden Globes.
Know the Martian.
Oh yeah.
How did that word Marshall and best
comments at work?
How does the Martian when best comedy
and comedy or musical category,
and I don't know how it gets,
why they still only comedy or musical.
This so offensive to both comedy and
music.
That's not a comedy and it's not a
musical.
Listen,
award shows or students call it other.
They're stupid award.
How did the Marsha when best comedy.
They're stupid because he made so he
kept it lighthearted sometimes.
Trying to be plus one.
The best one.
One W we've already established right
here between you and I.
The Shit I love that you hate,
but I genuinely love star wars.
Like I walked out of there going,
yes,
they fucking did it.
I walked out of there like they nailed
it.
They upgraded the original movie and
made it fit in today and he did it with
great acting and a great storyline.
It was perfect.
It was very star wars s fucking hated
it.
I didn't hate it,
but it's just like,
I thought it was like a b.
okay,
let's,
let's pays.
Good.
It was a fun movie.
Tell me some other movies that you've
seen recently.
So Star Wars would compare a hateful
eight.
No way you saw seen that?
Um,
uh,
I don't see that though.
I enjoyed madmax.
Yeah,
me too.
I thought it was really fun.
Chase,
you know,
Eddie Bravo.
None of those fucking hated it.
Really hated it.
There were none.
There was none of the points where I'm
like,
this wouldn't exist in that world.
I set up.
I'm like,
that wouldn't happen in star wars.
The world they set up.
It's like,
why is she suddenly have Jennifer
flowers with no training?
Well,
because there's a thing called editing,
there's probably a bunch of scenes that
were on the cutting room floor that
explain her power soil or this point
star wars.
Everyone's seen it.
You should really say,
spoiler alert first.
You really fucked up.
I'm sure we're already.
We're already open.
She just got it a little too fast and
then it's like,
well no.
She was the chosen one.
It's like,
oh,
like Luke Skywalker,
she was wanting to study for a month
with a fucking Yoda to get any of his
powers.
Well,
chicks learn quicker and they have no
chicken picker in their world and they
have that.
If you don't get it from as a kid,
you're never going to get it.
Well,
there's the thing called morphic
resonance and they think that like as
people learn,
things becomes easier for other people
to learn things.
We all learned together,
but she beat up.
It's beating up a storm trooper with it,
which I've been studying with the head
guy.
She had a guy who's been studying under
the main gracie and she was like,
I just sort of get Jujitsu and I think I
can beat this guy who's been studying
under the main gracie.
Bj Penn won the world championship three
years in.
Weird Shit happens man,
though.
He wasn't just like,
yeah,
but you know what?
You don't realize that she was using the
forest,
but she's probably using it all along.
It wasn't flood mode,
but you saw first week,
right?
What's first week?
First Week.
The first week or two was out.
Oh yeah.
That's why it was the same as the other
movie when it came out.
Episode one where everyone's like me to
like,
fuck yes,
this is way better than those.
But it was not as good as people were
remembering.
How dare you.
Were you in a theater when they clapped?
When they saw them letting him Falcon?
Um,
I clap almost brainwash week.
I almost cried.
I know.
Oh,
I hope they do the other things.
They've already done the lead.
Han Solo showed up.
My heart filled with joy.
I liked that.
That was fun.
I liked that a lot.
That was great.
With Chewie,
we're home like,
fuck.
Yes.
I liked that a lot.
They fucked up in that regard,
right?
Spoiler alert.
No,
there's no spoiler alerts anymore.
The chance.
Don't say it.
What if people like fast forward it and
they get to the part where we say Han
solo got killed.
There was a guy that I saw a picture of
somebody.
You know those things you can put in the
back of your truck,
like a the Smith family.
What Solo dies in the force awakens in
the Star Wars.
So rude.
That's really driving a rental or it's
big spoiler,
spoiler.
Fucking awesome movies with these
boilers.
You have a chance right then to get on
it or you're done.
I already knew I already knew going into
see the movie,
but we'd already been spoiler and
forget.
It had already been spoiled for me,
but I still enjoyed the phone.
Who's going out there to die?
I knew he was gonna die when he walked
out on that platform is like,
what do you do?
Obviously you shoot him.
Yeah.
Okay.
Why don't you shoot your stupid fucking
son,
late term abortion.
Sun come up.
Worst case scenario,
you one of the coolest guys of all time,
loved by millions,
and your son has just turned out to be
evil.
Went to the dark side.
Happens.
Oh,
by the way,
you had a son with Princess Leia.
So you get the fuck Princess Leia.
You know what you think?
A match made in heaven.
He's super heroic.
Swashbuckler with a giant big foot by
side during the hot princess and they
get together and fuck and they make an
evil baby that winds up killing Danny.
That's bullshit.
That is bullshit.
How much did it make you laugh when?
When that guy finally took off,
his Adam driver finally took off a
helmet and you're like,
fuck,
as a beautiful Semitic man.
He looked like an awesome magician.
Oh my God.
There was giggling where it's like you
as medic man.
He's gorgeous.
And that's.
There's no way those.
There was parents.
He's a gorgeous jus.
Wow.
Alright.
It's hot for that guy.
What's his name?
Kylo Ren.
So his name that was choppy James made
me back me up on that.
That was ridiculous.
And he pulls off his helmet was this
evil guy.
And let me back you up.
I'm right here,
Bro.
I'm not leaving you alone.
You didn't think that was done?
Oh,
it was ridiculous.
Perfect hair.
How does your hair stay perfect and
that.
Why isn't it sweaty?
There'd be no.
He's a full helmet.
He's a beautiful head of hair.
As soon as you pull it off,
it's like you just got to have a blow
out because he got his hair all blown
out like he's on the set.
You know he pulls this sweaty fucking
metal helmet off.
Do you?
I want you to be sweating in that stupid
thing where you're up killing people.
I mean,
he's killing people.
He's running around.
He's grabbing them and crushing them.
He's hacking things up with his fucking
sword.
Remember that
beautiful,
beautiful man.
That's that Chris says Leah and fucking
if that guy,
what's his name?
What's that guy's name?
Who's the actor?
Harrison Ford did not give birth to
that.
Listen,
if that guy acts like a dick to girls
and just bang,
someone ever calls them back.
It's not as fault.
No,
it's not his fault.
Look at him.
He's got powers,
gets super powers.
The force is strong with him.
Like for real.
Like the forced to bank checks.
It's very strong.
He might've abuse it.
He could get away from him driving it
before we do this take.
Yeah,
it's beautiful.
It's a ridiculous movie,
but I loved it.
I do like the,
the,
the theories of like there'll be
stormtroopers are like,
wait,
I'm not feeling this.
I liked it.
When they handle it,
it's like,
yeah,
keep checks on them all the time.
One,
I don't know how this one got
through.
Isn't it interesting that the first
storm trooper we see without a helmet,
black guy quit or you're saying the fuck
the first storm trooper?
No,
the first,
well the first quarter,
but they didn't concentrate on the storm
trooper helmet maybe,
but nobody paid attention to them were
the first one they pay attention to is a
black guy.
Interesting.
Diversity.
The version that is the case.
I think star wars is a case where you
could make the argument that even though
they might have gone towards diversity,
they nailed it.
A woman's a perfect fucking stopping
girl and the man who's a storm trooper
was like the right race or the sun's
going to be like gender.
Both of them seemed totally fine,
honestly,
hoping that the fighter pilot and the
storm trooper had a gay affair because
it seemed like they were,
they were really close,
like the way they,
the way they hugged,
they had like a deep embrace.
Oh,
how you been man?
Deep embrace there was so happy to see
each other.
So happy.
It was a lot like,
um,
when that movie,
uh,
what does the cowboy movie when they go
gay,
Black Mountain,
brokeback mountain.
It's almost like when those who hadn't
seen each other for a while and they
just start,
do they make it out together and they
just dove into each other's arms and
went after it?
Yeah,
I mean they live through life and death
out there with laser beams and shit.
People shooting at them,
they survived a crash,
landed together.
There's a bond with people,
they say that when people form
relationships after traumatic events,
like,
like if you met someone during nine
slash 11 and like you grabbed her,
come with me and you grabbed her hand
and you,
you ran and you guys both barely got out
of the building and the building
collapsed and you gotten a car and got
away together and then she's crying and
she stays in your apartment.
You want it falling in love.
You are fucking relationship will be
super intense because it's always going
to be connected to this one,
like really powerful event.
Like Christie Brinkley apparently had a
situation like that when she was in a
helicopter crash with this dude and then
wound up marrying the dude and then it
fell apart.
It doesn't make it look live with them.
I just feel like we together baby,
we're supposed to survive this together
and the bond that you have because you
sort of imprint on this moment like you
ever go somewhere where like you had a
really bad time and year round that area
and even 10 years later you'll still
feel shitty about it.
I remember this,
yes.
Deep emotional connection with somebody
that's like,
I have emotional connections with clubs
where I bombed.
I go by like,
like if I went by some places in Boston
and be like,
Ooh,
I remember eating Dick up their
restaurant now you're like,
I can't,
I can't eat here.
Yeah.
That's nothing.
Like people can develop some serious
emotional connections to areas.
Had that Tom Cruise movie that was
actually good that nobody saw.
Oh,
was that good?
Oh yeah.
Where he kept going back in time.
Oh wait a minute.
Oh,
that was really good.
Really good.
That was already given up on it from the
last one.
So.
But that was good and they handled
everything right.
Like that was happened.
This would happen.
You're like,
oh,
there it is.
It is.
But he had that girl so they kept trying
to fall in love with.
I mean figure it out.
Oh,
if we get to this stage in yesterday,
she's going to will follow them up and
let's just stay here and stay in love as
long as possible.
That's beautiful.
Yeah,
that's what I'd like.
I ain't never got to work out like that.
Those aliens were cool.
They weren't really original.
Who?
Robot aliens.
They were weird.
Sorta mechanical,
transforming alien things that just like
they were.
They were awesome because they were so
creative.
Like I'd never seen anything that I go,
oh,
that's like this.
Yeah.
They dropped them like cannon balls and
the,
the ground.
They're just like these,
like,
like a squids,
like maybe the coolest aliens in a movie
ever.
I mean these people are shooting at them
and it's like,
Oh,
you guys are done.
You have no chance.
Yeah.
They morphed and changed.
Maybe pull the video up so you could see
what that,
uh,
that scene was like because it's cool to
see the,
uh,
that looks like an illustration to
Frank Frazetta looking thing.
Do you know Frank Frazetta is no
heathen?
No.
Nothing.
Who is the customer is amazing artist
who used to do a Conan the barbarian.
Really?
Yeah.
Pull it before we go to this.
Pull up Frank Frazetta conant.
Just school this sad ban.
Frank Frazetta Conan.
Wait,
wait.
See this image motherfucker.
This guy was the shit.
And like the seventies.
Oh Wow.
Go with the one right next to it,
to the left of that.
That's the classic one.
Go full screen on that.
That's a classic classic.
So that's a real barbarian do.
That's Conan the barbarian.
That's what got me into those with a
girl,
a naked woman at his feet.
I was standing on top of Jesus.
The blood and bones and meat bones.
Got a hot girl.
Doesn't give a fuck.
She's a lying on the blood while he's
got a sword in.
Just want to hold onto your reasons.
He's covered in scars too.
It's got scars all over his face,
all over his arms.
That was what got me into Conan these
images by Frank Frazetta because they
created this superman,
the Sumerian barbarian who loves having
girls.
That has.
Of course he does.
That's the only reason why to fight with
a sword son.
Whilst if y'all can't get pussy,
they understood it back then.
Let's go to this one right now.
Sexist,
go.
Bam.
Sexism's alive.
He came in her 34 times.
That's got double sticks out.
No,
that's.
Come all Jane.
She's got her,
her vagina is so full of cum.
It's like pushing forward on an
abdominal wall that can cause Hernias,
shoot and lows in her and killing
people.
Like that was back before they even knew
what six packs were.
And he had a six pack.
No one has six pack in the seventies.
That guy,
they have perfect bodies.
They were bigger than any body builder.
Pretty cool.
Pretty cool paintings.
Well,
when Conan was played by Arnold
Schwartzenegger,
everybody,
like,
that's what everybody recognizes,
you know?
But yeah.
Yeah.
But the character in the present
drawings was much more.
Here's was a closer to comic strip
before.
Oh No,
no,
no.
It was a book a of books by a guy named
Robert e Dot Howard.
And Robert Howard is this really
fascinating guy.
They did a movie about him and the dude
from one of those cop shows the guy
from,
um,
you know what?
The dude from full metal jacket,
amazing actor from full metal jacket or
play.
The guy shot himself.
The guy will get bullied and everything.
He's amazing.
What is this fucking name?
Vincent.
Sorry Vincent.
He's amazing.
He's,
he's an amazing actor.
He wasn't going to say he's in it.
He's in a what?
A,
what the fuck are we just talk Conan?
Yeah,
going.
No,
he plays Robert Howard.
That's what it is.
He plays Robert e Dot Howard in a
biography on property.
Howard's life in a movie and I didn't
see the movie,
but Robert Howard was supposed to be
this like really strange guy who lived
with his mom and he shot himself I think
when he was 36,
so he had this like,
is that it?
The whole wide world.
He had some serious mental issues for
sure,
but he also,
he wasn't healthy and so he had imagined
this,
this superman,
this uber monch who was destroying
people back in this fictitious world
that he created that supposedly was a
long time ago,
but who knows,
you know,
it was like these,
these countries that never existed and
they were doing battle on this
witchcraft and demons and monsters.
And then there was this barbarian
usurper,
this king who became a king by killing
everything in his path.
He was like this indestructible man.
That's Conan the barbarian.
And so Robert e Dot Howard sort of
created this guy who's the antithesis of
what he was.
He was as frail guy who lived with his
mom.
He's a pussy and just he,
he wrote his longing about this guy,
this lust for adventure thing.
Everything killed,
everything always survived.
He was just this uber man,
the greatest of all time is giant man.
And moved like a panther who like had a
mind,
like a steel trap.
He would never show weakness.
He'll,
you know,
he'll always was ready to die but never
did.
So he wrote all these really bad ass
books.
They were really wild as probably now if
I read them and be like,
what am I reading?
But when I was 11 they were the shit
really stuff.
I'm sort of,
I kind of like get.
It wasn't like he put his hard cock in
her gut and it wasn't like that kind of
stuff.
It was like from antic,
you know,
like it was more about like cleaving
heads and,
and the Gore of him being covered with
Gore and bits of sinew cover the
glistening blade as a slices through the
attackers will,
you know,
and then they realize like how they
fucked up and try to do battle with
Conan and everybody died,
everybody dies.
But Conan,
but it was just this for a 12 year old
kid or whatever the fuck I was when I
guess I was probably like that age when
I got into it,
it was amazing.
It was like,
whew,
you know,
because you're a boy.
Like first of all,
no one's gonna let you see that you're
like a 12 year old boy.
They don't show it in movies.
They cut it.
Yeah.
You don't really even like today they
do.
Like today if you watched,
um,
a recent barbarian movie,
like there was,
they would show.
You see Jason Mamoa.
Have you seen him play Konan?
He's the guy from game of thrones.
Oh,
the real tall one.
Yeah,
the,
well,
the really handsome guy that dies early.
This dude,
that dude is a cool motherfucker.
I ran into him recently at whole foods.
He couldn't be cooler.
I've ran into with the UFC before too.
He's just a really nice,
really friendly guy who uh,
you want to hate him because he's a
little too beautiful.
Little too beautiful,
a little too tall.
But he was my favorite all time Conan
because he,
that's what Kona is supposed to be
built.
Like maybe we'll do it on TV show now.
He did a movie.
It was really,
it was kind of a shit movie
unfortunately.
But um,
it's cool to watch anyway.
I enjoyed it.
But Tim is going in.
Yeah,
he's a good size for Kona and like that
would be like with Conan would be built
well you'd have a chance to win like
everyone of your hand to hand combat
battles.
Yeah.
He wouldn't be built like Arnold
Schwarzenegger if you look at the data
drawing.
So like go to the,
the [inaudible] with the sword again,
the St,
the classic one.
It's a little bit over there right there
apparently.
So like the real Kona is like a little
more built in him,
but that's probably because a homeboys
on the couch.
No,
Jason,
my mom was like,
that's actually what he's really built,
like sports and Agora was filled with 32
pounds,
the Mexicans supplements and then give
them time.
You know,
when he played killing enemy,
nobody's built like that when he was
Conan.
I mean he had the most ridiculous
fucking body.
Schwartzenegger was number one in the
world body.
Well he's slimmed down though.
He slimmed down towards the other ones
like you see Kinda tell a difference
between that one and the other one that
you just had those monster huge.
It's so big.
And by the way that's small,
like right there,
like that's very slim in comparison.
Like that's a guy who is slimming down.
Like that guy is built like tyron what?
The body of the drawings.
Yeah,
that's perfect.
Actually.
That must have been one of the later
movies.
So I think like he went from being the
bigger bodybuilder.
It looks so weird to see him with that
fucking chest and the sword and a
backwards baseball cap on backwards
baseball hat.
Right.
Was like a little it go back up.
Does he really have one yet?
Backers that almost looks like,
but it's a Bandana.
It could be a bag.
You can be like a hillbilly with a sword
who's really yolked really old
hillbilly.
Slimmed down.
He was still massive,
you know,
even when he got smaller.
But if you go back to is bodybuilding
days when he was Mr Olympia.
Holy Shit.
He in my opinion,
out of all like the bodybuilders styles,
like there's a bunch of different
styles.
Like now guys are just massive and
shredded.
Yeah.
Well that guy is the guy on the left is
the foxes multiple time.
Mr Olympia,
what the Hell's his name?
Because it has legs.
It'll gross.
What is
his name?
God dammit.
Jamie,
what does it say?
Ronnie Coleman.
So that's not real.
Ronnie Coleman was many years later.
Right?
So that's just a comparison to the two
of them.
Oh,
I see.
Okay.
See if you it back up again.
Go back to that image again,
please.
That's really amazing there.
Yeah,
but if you go back to that image,
the one.
Yeah,
look at the difference in the legs.
That's the real difference.
Ronnie Coleman's legs are massive.
They're insane.
They don't seem real.
See Arnold seem ridiculously muscular as
well,
but real.
How does he wear shirts,
Goldman,
either their waists or narrow.
Why would you were closer?
You're built like that.
Just walk around this little grape
smugglers all day just to let everybody
know what the fuck is up.
He can't stay like that for very long
either.
That's the other thing you have to
realize when you're looking at these
athletes.
Should I call them athletes?
Bodybuilders?
Yeah.
I think they're a little bit different
than an athlete.
I mean,
it's obviously what their muscles get
tired and they can't.
Well,
yeah,
they're,
they're in the state of massive
dehydration there.
Uh,
they can't maintain that very long.
It's super dangerous when guys get,
um,
that,
that dehydrated like that they can't
hang on for very long.
They don't have much endurance.
You know,
you're feeling really tired all the
time,
but that's how you get your skin really
thin.
Like a lot of those guys,
when they do that,
they're fucking exhausted while they're
doing it,
but they maintain a good face and flex
just crazy what people do to their
bodies.
Like even then like you look at that,
which is big giant,
but they're the guys who are so much
bigger today.
Like you see them there
or something.
Trump.
Who's the guy to the left?
Is that Franco Columbo?
Because guys about to lose.
Some days we thought it had a future.
Well,
there's a lot of those guys that did
have a future.
They just never had a future like him,
but he's just said crazy ambitious
motherfucker.
You know her,
her burns bit about him.
No bird has a bit of a.
Oh yeah,
a great man.
That's right.
That's what after you bang is made.
Yeah.
No,
you can do all these things.
They tell them,
you can't come to America,
be a bodybuilder.
You're just some German.
You came,
you're going to win.
You won the biggest bodybuilder.
Well,
you can't what?
You want to be a movie star?
No,
you can't be a movie star.
It's come on.
You should work bodybuilding.
You can't say you did it.
Alright,
that's enough.
You've done enough with.
You're the biggest movie star in the
world.
All right,
well that's it.
Now stop.
You can't run California.
That's not allowed.
You're a movie star bodybuilder and all
you're doing.
You're doing it.
I bet.
Now you want to fuck it made of course.
Oh,
to the line.
That's what brought them down.
Yeah,
a great man.
A great man.
I think if they didn't have law against
it,
a law against it because he was born in
another country president.
He wasn't president.
I think he could be president now.
No bullshit.
He's too far removed from his face and
find a new woman,
new woman that really anchors them other
than the woman who is religious.
I mean she's not like crazy about it,
but there's something about Jesus's
teachings,
so it's really starting to appeal to
arnold as he gets older in life,
and then boom,
connects with that.
Report that data to get Jesus in real
rural.
Pop it over to Jesus forgives.
You could get Jesus to just listen.
Jesus said some cool shit.
Okay.
He just did.
He really did.
He did some cool.
If it was a real guy,
which is debatable,
right?
It's a lot of.
Not a lot of evidence that there was a
real guy.
I wrote about him and Tom Joad.
Did they know what else they write about
dragons?
Anything about witches and demons?
No.
It's not the one that tells you if you
jerking off.
No.
Oh,
the other one?
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't know.
What do you think?
I think it was real.
I think they did have historical
evidence for them,
but not the powers.
Now they're walking,
I'm walking.
You ever seen that movie?
There's a lot of shit.
It's like,
okay.
Before the internet,
you remember those videos of that Sensei
who's like trying to rush me and just
with one finger who draws people back
and they'll fly,
but it's clearly faked.
Before,
there were videos of that,
they were just,
dude,
I heard this guy can knock off any
attacker with one finger and I don't
have tv either.
So I don't know what's real.
That's what Jesus does.
Jesus got big.
Well,
here's the thing,
people are telling stories about them.
The idea,
Jesus coming back from the dead,
right?
That was the big one,
That was probably one of the biggest
ones he did.
Um,
and then what it is later and then what
happens?
He goes away.
What happened?
So yeah,
I think he just cut.
They're like,
oh look,
his body's not in here.
He must've come back from the dead.
He couldn't be that hyenas eight his
body or anything right now.
Or somebody just would grave rob,
why don't you leave a body out and no,
no,
he's,
he's back up again.
And then he went to heaven.
So he came back to life once a heaven.
Jamie,
do you know,
put him in a tomb.
They put them into them right in front.
And three days later the rockers moved
and people's,
someone saw him go up into heaven,
full body.
Oh,
this lion bitch.
So Dome of the Rock is worse,
still went up to heaven.
You know who saw him?
Those lesbians in that club,
Vancouver,
they were their,
their,
their account is totally tribunals.
Have too much power.
Yeah.
If you had a Canadian tribunals to
discover whether or not Jesus ever came
back to life,
I just think if you came back to life
should probably stick around.
Talk to people.
Let them know that you did it.
Look,
I'm so for real.
You guys crucified me?
Not Again,
bitch.
Come at me this time.
I'm going to use my magic.
I'm here to fix you guys.
Come on,
die for your sentence.
Get it together.
Bitches.
Nope.
Removing anything we know is not true
from that.
How do you know it's not true?
Well,
no shit.
From what you know,
let's say a atheist or agnostic.
That's the guy who got strung up for
saying he was a messiah,
which he wasn't the only one at a time
thing is messiah.
He got strung up for it and he died and
the followers had to keep hope alive and
whatever they did,
they did,
but like if it was a real person,
then it's like,
yeah,
he got,
he got killed.
Like a lot of people.
Well,
it's so hard.
It's so hard to recount the truth in an
accurate way from things you've actually
experienced.
Yeah.
Now I'm managing the god out of it.
Those still.
But imagine
those stories of whoever he was counted
down and in and re retold by people that
barely remember the word innovation.
They weren't even the region.
They added their own bullshit to it.
Like people do the added their own
spice.
They have their own rules,
their out of their own happy ending or
sad ending or consequences of said
action,
you know,
and Jesus said,
if you do not cover from your eyes to
your,
to your ankles,
you shall be stoned to death and the
dishonor telling like you people just
add shit.
Right?
Who knows what the original message was
and who the fuck it was that came up
with it.
It might've been to some really cool
dude wanted everybody to get along and
so they decided to kill this fucker
because he's talking shit.
Imagine if the Romans came to town.
They got their swords and ready to kick
some ass and this fucking hippie is over
here talking some stupid shit.
No,
dude,
we're here to kill people.
Okay.
We're just going to nail you to this
cross like we do.
Thousands of other fucking people.
As a matter of fact,
they had.
What was the story that there's a story
in history on fire that Danieli Bull Lee
talks about where the Romans,
they put miles and miles of crucified
bodies on this road.
I can get my thrones.
Dude.
It's horrific.
When he recounts it,
it's horrific and they did that.
So why would they give a shit about
doing this to one other dude will let
them do whatever they want.
Because.
So if you were in the town,
and this is one cool guy wants everybody
to get along and you're like,
man,
I'm glad Jesus is here.
He's talking sense.
You know,
we really should listen to him.
I'm like,
why are we being assholes?
We really do.
We appreciate our,
our,
our surroundings and,
and love each other like brothers and
sisters.
Oh Shit,
dude.
The Romans look over the hill.
Fuck,
and you look over the hill and you see
dust and horses.
Thousands of them coming forth.
This dude's gonna step up and try to
talk,
laid down and
chop his fucking dick off and stuff it
up his nose.
They're monsters.
That's why I love game of thrones.
They don't fuck around.
They're not like.
They were just like,
this is how it would be a bunch of loose
cannons.
Oh yeah.
No,
no.
Government oversight.
Die Cellphone reason why take the chance
of sorts to die by the sword heads and
fucking arms get lopped off.
Well,
I've always hated the crossbow.
Takes too long to reload to bullshit
weapon.
It really is.
Crossbows,
we're putting the kid a fucking bow,
folks.
A real bone out.
Does that make you mad?
Walking dead and it makes me mad.
No,
it makes me mad.
The walking dead.
I.
He's one of the coolest college.
How does that fucking Arrow not get a
pass through?
Okay.
He's shooting people in the bodies.
He should always.
It always sticks out and he pulls it
right out.
Listen man,
I ruined three or four hours a week,
a week.
This guy has been out there.
It's finding new arrows.
I shoot a lot of arrows and sometimes
when I'm practicing with the New Georgia
new releases,
I'm practicing a new archer releases.
Sometimes I hit rocks and shit and they
just break break.
I'm exaggerating the amount per hit a
rock on purpose.
It just destroys the arrows.
The arrows going too fast just shatters
and explodes.
But my point being like,
this guy has the same goddamn arrows.
Like,
where's he?
These arrows are gone,
dude.
You shot a hundred zombies anymore.
Arrows.
You just don't.
You're not going to pull them out.
They're going to be perfect.
First of all,
you have field points and that's
bullshit.
Anyway.
You don't even have broad heads.
Again,
I make to put a little pinhole in.
It just shoots him in the head,
you know,
and it just sticks right in there
magically and he pulls it right out.
Like what are their heads made of?
Yeah,
I know the long and where did they.
When they eat,
what?
What happens to the food?
They don't.
Their bodies don't still work in
process.
Stuff is way better off with a regular
bone arrow because irregular bone.
Our look,
you can make your own bone now.
That'd be better than that stupid
fucking crossbow.
You.
You want something?
You can just load up like that and keep
shooting.
You can shoot several times.
That stupid thing.
You've got to grab it.
You've got to pull it.
People just like it because it looks
like Chewbacca his gun in Star Wars.
It's some old school shit like you
think,
oh,
that's even better than no bone marrow.
Bone ours way better than a crossbow.
Unless you're a pussy.
You don't want to learn how to shoot a
bow and arrow.
They should buy walking dead with her
actual bow and Arrow had those guys butt
heads.
I mean,
it's not a bad weapon.
If you want to kill something,
like if you want to use it,
like if you,
if you're in a deer blind and you're
trying to kill a deer and you want to
show someone how to do it with a
crossbow,
it's a great weapon for that because
it's really easy to do everything.
Sebastian's pit about bow and arrow.
No,
he's got a good bit.
Don't tell me.
Don't say don't say don't say I don't
want it to go.
Okay.
I'll trailer.
A lot of his act outs are so good.
He's such a good dude too.
It's cool seeing a guy like him.
You've got to look it up.
I don't want to play it.
It is,
yeah.
I'll find it later.
But for,
for folks listening co go,
go check it out.
But I mean like most people don't
actually have a bow and Arrow,
so if anyone would like this bit is
these fucking funny man.
And he's a really nice guy too.
That's cool.
He's one of those guys where everybody
likes him.
I've never heard anybody doesn't like
Sebastian.
You know?
One person doesn't like Sebastian.
Yeah.
Ever.
No.
That's why it's cool to just,
yeah,
this is just a.
But he's also a guy that like really
worked hard.
That guy,
he hustled,
man.
He made it happen for himself.
He kept getting better,
but
that was his catchphrase.
Couldn't do that without doing that.
He came in and did a podcast and he was
fucking hilarious.
He's hilarious.
He was really so like particular.
Yeah.
Very particular.
Like what's going on with your
fingernails?
It looks and it just bothers them.
Or like what?
What,
what,
what is this?
What is this?
Paint your fingernails.
Yeah.
He's another guy that has like a very
specific style.
His clean.
Think about it,
man.
I don't know.
Think about it.
No,
I got it.
I'm going to say no.
I've seen them before.
Maybe just one of those crowd work,
but it's crowded because everything's.
He lifts everybody up instead of shirts.
Gross.
He goes,
that's shirts.
Amazing.
Couldn't never get away with that shirt.
Look at how gorgeous this guy.
There's.
Smile.
You got all your teeth fixed,
Huh?
Beautiful.
He takes the opposite end of it and just
get get the money out of just being
positive.
That's interesting.
That's in that sense.
Maybe.
Yeah.
Maybe that sense.
Which is the act.
Exactly the exact opposite of what I
used to love about watching dies in the
or just hurting people.
There'd be a guy.
He goes,
look at you,
look at you.
The last piece of pussy you saw is the
last piece of pussy over Africa.
Trust me,
trust me.
It's over.
He would have a cigarette.
It's sophie.
Who's going to fuck you gonna.
Fuck though.
Victory Shits on you,
but leave.
Who's going to fuck you?
You're going to pay for it.
You're going to be sad.
You're going to fall in love with the
hookah.
Bring him into your life in Sydney.
Meanwhile,
all the time she's getting God looking.
He would just go deep,
but it was fun.
Like it was theater.
It was theater.
It didn't seem real,
right?
No,
no,
no.
It's it's theater like it's a character
that's doing this mean act.
When you act like yourself on stage,
people feel way more like how dare you,
but when it's complete character or a
movie where it's like dissolve,
definitely not true.
So it's okay.
Just seems more like reality.
I think that's why people get mad or
more of stand up.
Look to the head.
Is that good?
Yeah.
She bowie dying.
Fuck.
What'd you think of him?
I loved him.
Yeah.
I saw the exhibit and Melbourne is Bowie
Exhibit.
He had multiple songs.
Yeah.
I just.
The way he dealt with like live
performance and like getting costumers,
like hitting the world's best customers.
Like I got to talk to you.
And then he were just like,
here's what I'm kind of doing now.
I want you to design something with me.
I forgive him for dancing in the street
to the street with him and Mick Jagger.
Forgive them.
I forgive them for arguably the most
confusing sexually.
It leads to a young man.
I'm like,
what is happening with
him and Mick Jagger?
I was like,
what is this message?
You're confusing the fuck out of me.
I don't know what you guys are doing.
I want to know,
are you guys put tonic friends just
start dancing for some strange reason or
it seems like you're flirting with each
other like I need to know.
I need to know because all the time.
Well,
Mick Jagger's ex wife got mean said she
found a David Bowie and bed with
mcjagger,
so she told everybody that's where when
you're a guy like David Bowie or mick
jagger becomes really problematic being
married to some normal person because
she's got this amazing story.
So what if they want to get together and
figure out whether or not there was
like,
oh yeah,
I fuck all sorts of stuff like this a
shot.
Let's see what the fuck happens.
And meanwhile this woman that Mick
Jagger supposedly had some sort of a
contract with where they're not supposed
to have sex with other people.
She got all upset and she fucking puts
them on blast all over the world.
Probably put it in a book or something.
How rude to each other.
Listen,
that's privileged information,
ma'am.
That's not like regular people.
That's not like Bob,
you know the guy who fixes bikes,
the bike shop and Tim who's the ups
driver,
has friendly conversations with Bob and
the gun to them fucking in the men's
room.
It's not.
This is a bigger deal.
This is.
This is gonna affect the record
companies is gonna affect venues can
affect the people that sell tickets.
There's a lot of jobs attached to these
two people and you're just being rude
because you're a petty con.
What do you care?
Look at the way he's dressed.
Of course he fucks guys.
Jesus Christ.
That was a shocker to you.
Doesn't make them any less.
Awesome.
It makes them more awesome.
Look it up.
These guys from behind you there.
You imagine if you and I did a music
video and we were doing this,
what are you doing?
You can do this.
These thickness fingers couldn't kiss
each other for more than two seconds for
a hilarious thing on a pay per view
event.
How much?
My biggest regret is that it's pulling
away and laughing when I shouldn't have.
I didn't realize I thought the cameras
did.
You give him a ton and I give him a
little.
Did you.
What?
Did he give it back?
You think?
I don't like Dunkin,
but did he give it back?
We did.
You guys tongue?
We were.
We were locked in there,
man.
I thought you guys were like just just
lips.
I didn't know you went in tongues.
You gotta sell it.
Oh,
you sold was trench coat.
Is he warm or cold or what is he?
What is he?
Because it seems like they're both in
different climates.
Yeah,
like David Bowie,
he seems like he's in a rainy London
sorta climate,
but Mick Jagger's in the keys.
The Florida keys.
He's having a good old time.
He's like,
listen to Jimmy Buffet music or some
shit with c eight at night.
Blue Pants.
What's going on with you?
What's that about why they freeze frame
on that,
but does that you.
Did you do that Jamie,
or is that the actual video?
That's how it ends.
That's unfortunate or fortunate
depending on what you're really into.
Doing ground control to major Tom.
Come on,
man.
That's like startups character and he
all coked up.
They had these coke spoons as part of
the exhibit,
his,
all of his cooks,
but they didn't hide anything.
Did they really?
Yeah.
So in his coke rage or whatever he was
in,
he goes,
uh,
there's this famous thing.
He goes not only as a,
you guys have been wonderful audience
and not only is this the last,
uh,
ziggy stardust show of the tour,
but it is also in the band,
has no idea what he's talking about,
what he's going to say,
because this is also the last day he
started us show of all time.
He plays,
his last song gets off and the bands
like,
wait,
we're done with.
That's how you're telling us we're
fucking done.
Holy Shit.
That sucks for the band.
Yeah.
And then he went and started just being
David Bowie wow.
Here this character.
That was huge.
And they're like,
what are you doing?
Don't stop.
He goes,
fuck this.
I'm an artist.
I'm developing stuck with that
moneymaker forever.
Wow.
Well,
he was,
he was just,
he had some fucking really amazing songs
but amazing songs.
And they were so original.
Yeah.
But his live performance,
they showed them on the top of the pops,
just like androgynous shit on like a
late night talk show.
Not late for.
She'll lecture like a mainstream thing
and they just like almost half kissing
this guy and people are like,
wait,
what the fuck was that?
What did I just see?
Yeah.
And the music was so unique.
[inaudible],
you know,
his style was,
it was just,
it was very specific.
You know,
was very David Bowie.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
What a great song.
That is.
Yeah,
he was awesome,
man.
It wasn't like,
okay,
when Michael Jackson died,
everyone's a Michael Jackson Fan.
Everybody right when he died it was sad,
whatever.
But he wasn't still making music and
stuff,
you know?
So it was like,
oh,
it's too bad he passed.
But it was either that or 30 years later
we weren't going to miss out on
anything.
David Bowie released an album last
Tuesday.
They did.
Really?
Yeah.
It's just getting the first hit is just
on the radio right now.
He still has stuff that's being planned
for radio releases in the next.
You know,
humor like there was a rollout scheduled
fucking cancer man.
He did a lot of stuff,
allegedly.
I don't even think he hid from it.
Yeah.
It's a bummer man.
Bummer.
Did you see the Sean Penn thing on Sean
Lynch,
Chapo.
Sean Penn.
I've completely changed my opinion about
him.
I think he was a blowhard.
Linda did that chris rock thing.
I was very critical of him because the
chris rock made a joke and he's doing
his monologue and he made a joke about
jude law and sean penn comes out and
goes,
well,
the reason margaret,
like,
come on man,
you know,
so I goofed on them.
But that fucking guy went to Mexico to
the jungle to meet el chapo and
interview him and write about it for
rolling stone.
Wow.
Just to be a journalist,
dude.
He has everything to lose.
He's got a family,
he's got children,
he's got money,
he's got fame,
he's got everything.
He has no reason to want to do this.
And he decides to do it.
He decides to and people who are
criticizing him and it's really bizarre
way that first of all they said was one
of these guys said,
I read this tweet about it where you're
saying,
I wonder how sean penn feels about real
journalists being killed,
you know,
because of the narco is have killed
journalists that report on them.
Well guess what?
He's risking his life like you don't
think they would think it would be funny
to kill sean penn.
Like if,
if,
if somehow another sean penn had
irritated el chapo.
El chapo decided to have him killed.
It must've known the risk of that.
This guy doesn't care.
El chapo got out and tunnels.
I heard he was hiding out and justin
martindale's asshole.
I don't think justin martindale's
assholes that little.
That's how.
No,
I'm saying that's the series of tunnels
and if you looked in there,
you know,
I mean that big a.
So we interviewed el chapo.
That's cool.
He went to Afghanistan during the
beginning of the war to right,
or a wreck.
One of those two street.
I don't.
I'm not sure about that.
I didn't.
I wasn't aware of that,
but what he did with el chapo was he got
in touch with some mexican actress who
knows el chapo,
she's probably ghetto chapels,
trembling sign and um,
el chapo,
uh,
arranged a meeting and uh,
they had like specific conditions like
what?
He had to read the story before it's
published,
which they've never granted before with
rolling stone.
They don't do that and they agreed to it
because it's just like such a critical
to illegally.
I'm not gonna let you me that it's sean
penn is interviewing,
but all these journalists are mad.
And Like what sean penn responsible for
the fact that el chapo was killed.
Other people like he shouldn't be
sitting down and talk.
You don't want a c,
a conversation and it's kilograms.
he is being a journal,
a killer.
But okay,
let's interview him.
But manson,
what does this kid shit like real
journalists like don't say that.
Like that guy.
That's a Crazy risk.
he took undeniably crazy risk.
Just cattiness for anybody to shit on
it.
Like to say that he shouldn't have done
that.
Like he's not going to keep people alive
by not going there.
He's,
and in fact,
they believe that the paper trail or the
electronic trail of them setting this up
is probably what led to them capturing
el chapo in the first place.
So really,
which they just did the whole thing it.
And then he just,
they only caught them like two days ago
and they caught them like,
right as this story is coming out with
almost of americans still fucking
rolling stone setup el chapo to make
their stores selling from better.
JamIe.
So are you thinking,
oh,
I can't believe you're saying that.
I don't know why you would say that
because I don't think the world works
that way.
God,
jamie's like conspiracy.
They sell the extra stuff.
We just come down.
They want to,
they,
the United States is going to give
Mexico like a bunch of why?
Because he gasoline or struggles that
come here.
Uh,
because yeah,
he sold drugs in America.
So we get to pull them out of his
country of have jurisdiction because
they can't keep that fucker locked up.
We can keep them locked up.
They're like,
enough to help us with is withholding
this joker.
He fucking escaped twice.
We're done with this.
Let's stop.
I just,
uh,
I've completely changed my opinion on
sean penn.
What are you on p?
Yeah,
I knew it.
The interview was in october.
It wasn't october.
It was just coming out now.
Right.
Which might be added to your.
It might be added to.
Why?
Why would release it now?
Conspiracy member.
It's illuminati controls all of the
media.
Do you think you'd get in trouble for,
for doing this at all?
Sean penn?
Yeah.
Fuck yeah,
foR sure.
Yeah.
Look,
man,
he,
he just got a story with one of the
biggest drug dealers or the apparently
the biggest drug dealer.
If he's to be believed ever it's ever
lived other than the other that's ever
lived,
allegedly.
come on,
man.
I mean,
of course you can get in trouble for
that.
That's a dangerous move.
Like anybody that says that what sean
penn did didn't take any courage.
It's crazy in anybody who's like,
why criticize it?
Just look at it.
What it is,
what he got.
He had a conversation with a a known
gangster of incredible reputation.
I mean,
that's what that guy is.
He's an unknown gangster of incredible
reputation and sean penn met him in the
jungle in Mexico.
You don't think that's a ballsy move.
That's one of the ballsiest moves that a
person can do as a journalist,
but with sean penn did,
but to do it as a movie star,
a fucking guy who's won oscars or at
least an oscar,
right?
He's warning us ranks.
Look,
he's a bad motherfucker.
I rescind my previous criticism,
very big of you.
I heard that it was obviously a
conspiracy thing,
but I heard that the mexican government
might have led el chapo out to get the
cartels and gangs under control because
once they arrested him vacuum,
there was a vacuum.
Now that he was out,
he got everything wrapped up.
Now that pulled back in,
which is why he's been arrested again.
Jamie's with conspiracies over here
that's on the radio today.
How dare you to repeat these problems?
Oh,
who the fuck knows?
I don't think they let him out.
I think.
I think somebody paid a shitload of
money to have so many dig a tunnel and I
don't think they do a good job of
watching their prison.
That's most like or probably there's
probably some people in on it.
Probably got paid to.
Definitely write that.
That's why they're so that's why they
want to keep them here in the good old
us way.
We've got them locked down when we're
done with this shit.
I'm going to take them down to quantico,
put them down in place.
We got there.
And the bottom of the denver airport,
that's where he is comparing that.
Denver airport prison flights,
they always talk about.
I want to see that place.
Um,
yeah.
So I'm pretty sure it's bullshit.
It was a jail down there.
I think.
A lot of jail.
Wow.
Yeah,
it doesn't.
Fenway park have a jail too.
I might've made that up.
I don't know.
I can see that.
Um,
but yeah.
So I'll chop.
I'll captured.
And sean penn brody.
Cool.
Then he went down there and fucking it'S
not the best story.
Writing musical to work will dry and
Points.
But uh,
but you still say it's wrong for him to
go,
like he's one of our finer sectors.
What he did was just unnecessary and he
was just trying to stand up for a guy
that he has for his craft who doesn't
get comedy.
Right.
But it's his craft that's he doesn't
have to be who he is to be able to do
harvey milk and to also be able to do
the fast times at ridgemont high and the
irish mob guy,
like he's,
he obviously knows how to get into his
work.
He doesn't do a shit job.
Like he's not doing an american sniper.
Right.
If you ever seen a movie where he plays
it,
where it seems like he's just phoning it
in like,
like moments you saw american sniper,
you're like,
this is not real,
you know,
you don't see sean penn and those movies
in that.
Like when here's like the scene where
you're criticizing the bradley cooper
scene where the girlfriend was banging
another guy and it just seeMs all fake.
Could you imagine sean penn and that
saying,
no,
of course you can.
It would be.
It would,
he would figure out how to make it more
to shut up,
brother.
He would,
he would figure out how to make it more
real or he wouldn't be doing it.
Like his quality of work is definitely
to be respected.
Like there's a few guys like that that
have that Daniel Day lewis,
you know him,
a russell crowe.
There's like,
there's a few that have this
ability to like,
transform into like mariel hemingway,
a russell crowe puts out some stuff,
although he's dunaway may.
Faye dunaway.
Like from the beginning,
man,
you ever watch the original stoner?
That's the original rendition of a
stoney.
Everyone else is doing an impression of
that map wasted already.
Beats a sneaker or gets his head.
That was my head was.
How did you,
uh,
did you ever see chinatown?
Faye dunaway?
I don't know.
Good lord.
Jack nicholson to faye dunaway in
chinatown.
Oh shit.
Yeah.
There's,
there's some fuckIng people you know
who's that broad?
That's a in all the coen brothers
movies.
She's really awesome.
She was in fargo.
She's amazing.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
He was already out with the acts.
God damn it.
She was in the movie fargo.
She's Been in everything.
Yeah.
She's been in the movie fargo.
Frances mcdormand.
Yes.
She's.
She's one of those people that become
you.
It's.
I don't.
Yeah.
I don't care that she.
I know who it is.
Like she's so good.
Like you lose yourself.
Yeah.
If I go to see a movie and I'm like,
oh,
that's that guy.
How'd that guy get to play that guy?
It doesn't make any sense.
Like,
how is.
Wait a minute.
You know seth rogan is steve wasniak.
Nobody's not.
Seth rogen like,
what's going on here now?
He's playing somebody.
It's not that seth rogan's not good,
but you know what I mean?
Like I know who he is,
but she's so goddamn good.
You don't care who she is.
You don't care that it's frances
mcdormand.
When she's playing a role,
you bought hook,
line and sinker.
You're locked up in it,
which is way harder to do.
You know?
It's way harder to do when you don't
know who the person is.
Like an ax maki.
Now I didn't know who any of these
fucking people were,
so it was perfect.
It just slipped right in,
but if one of those people have been tom
cruise or the other one was nicole
kidman had been like,
come on like this.
I know who you are,
fucker.
It's hard to see whenever your friend's
book anything and you're watching a
movie and you see like the or,
or anybody you know or you know,
Missouri.
Bronto,
like,
um,
ah.
Yeah.
It's just real hard to get lost in it.
Almost imponderable know them bowl plus
it's not fun to get lost in it and it's
fun to go.
What's up?
That's what's fun,
right?
Yeah.
Cut.
Damn.
At ari shaffir are you enjoying your new
found success yet?
Man,
it's been great.
I get a little worried about certain
things.
I keep track of who traveled all over
the world though.
Having all the world's real fun as shit
I'm trying to do.
I realized I made this problems with
morrissey.
Paul morrissey a few years ago,
we were in a Denmark for some comedy
festival.
Nope.
Excuse me.
We're in montreux Switzerland for some
comedy festival and then went to
amsterdam afterwards and uh,
just for fun.
And we were like,
let's go to new countries every year.
Wow.
just to visit or to work,
whatever.
Either one.
Yeah.
I mean I've really.
One of the things I'd like to do in
another country to see what it's like to
do comedy there.
You should do a show in Thailand.
Thailand.
How many shows?
Just onE in bangkok.
How was it?
Fun as shit.
Wow.
That was a lot more thai people where
they there.
Then in China,
China was all ex pats.
Maybe one chinese person.
Wow.
Hong kong has been
mixed,
but like Thailand,
they speak some english dudes.
So I might do a show in India this year.
They speak english in India.
That's how when you get your computer
fixed.
English.
India in India,
everybody speaks english so they don't
have to do it for not just experts,
but either way,
if you have an american express issue,
you're talking to someone in India
pretty crazy.
Found that out and then we named
wonderful.
They're renamed them.
My name is fred.
I am here today,
but he's a problem with your phone card,
man.
I'm manic unexpressed.
that has again,
a racist.
Just like he was saying this to most
sword,
this is more racist.
You're appropriating an accent.
No,
it's racist for they renamed those
people.
That's racist.
Yeah.
Clearly I don't think american doesn't
someone have a bid on that?
Someone has a bit.
I had a bit,
I used to have a bit about it was it,
you know,
eddie bravo had a real problem with
those people one point in time.
And you know,
eddie bravo is a real trickster.
He's hilarious.
Like eddie must have ordered like a um,
a prescription medication and used his
cell phone as the phone number.
You know,
like when you,
you get a prescription,
like what number do you leave?
He left his cell phone.
So somehoW or another that got,
this was like in the early two thousands
and somehow or another that got sold as
a list,
you know,
how that happens out.
Like oh,
this guy buys prescription drugs or this
guy.
Uh,
but as solar panels,
and it sounds like for whatever reason
you get a list that was like a big issue
with people.
They would sell your information.
So he started getting all these phone
calls from pharmacies and they lose
people that barely spoke english and
they're trying to sell him prescription
drugs because this was during the day
where there was a kind of a wild west
period where you'd buy all your drugs
from Canada and overseas and they would
ship them and so you could get things
without a prescription,
like really heavy stuff without a
prescription.
And so eddie would keep these people on
the phone for ever.
I mean forever.
He would have these conversations with
them and pretend that like some noises
going on in the background and he would
talk to him and say,
what do you have that I can use?
Oh hold on,
I'll be right back.
I have to clean my feet.
And then he would go and like put the
phone down for like five minutes and go
take a leak.
He would get something to drink and then
come back to it and then start talking
to them about what different drugs like
I text,
what do you have that gets your card?
Do you have anything that gets your dick
hard and like have these crazy
conversations with these people and they
would go on forever.
Man.
He would be laughing.
It would hold the phone up to his chest
and he loves playing tricks like that on
people especially like he felt he had
the green light because they're
contacting him so he would drag on
forever.
Hang up though,
let's be curse.
Exactly.
So he was dragging it on forever and he
would go to like give them an address to
send it to her credit card number.
But then he would have some ridiculous
excuse.
He had to put the phone down,
he put the phone down for like 10
minutes and then go back to it and pick
it up,
keep doing it.
And it was Just one second.
I need to deal with this idea of like
crazy fake arguments,
you know,
like in the background,
hold the phone down
and fucking scream and yell.
And then you say he was about to get
raped and he called the police and video
record them.
No,
it was just for fun.
Just kept doing it for the of.
He would do it for like I'm telling you,
man,
he did a bunch of sort of remember
those.
You remember those?
Yeah.
Dude.
He would get excited when the phone
would ring.
Hello.
so what is the structure?
So glad you guys called me.
Yeah.
It just don't have that kind of
patience.
I don't have that mind either.
Got be bored.
You shouldn't be bored.
You got to be crazy.
Huh?
In a different way.
He loves doing that though.
He just.
He gets such a kick out of doing that or
he did.
I'm sure now he's too busy.
It's hilarious.
Yeah.
They don't do that anymore.
And do that call you.
It's supposed to not have your cell
phone.
I'll be like,
what am I supposed to call my cell phone
ever?
That was like a law change.
Imagine if they didn't know the lord.
I think it only came for when people
didn't have unlimited phone calls.
Wasn't like standard.
Like,
Hey,
you're using other people's fucking time
and money.
That's actually a good argument to keep
it the way it is.
Yeah,
because now they can be like,
what,
what's the difference?
Because if it's free,
if you get all the minutes in the world
all the time,
then people were free to contact you for
no reason.
Even fax machines,
as soon as we had fax machines within,
it was spam.
Spam,
just sending you some fucking ad.
You remember when you call someone on
the facts,
but she went answer.
Uh huh.
He blogged you mother fucker.
Ridiculous.
Yeah.
Alright.
Sphere,
we're out of time.
We've got to wrap this pitch up.
Conflicts some dates or something.
Do you just ran your hour special or you
register in my new.
YeaH,
in the belly room.
I walked in for a little bit,
so cell phone bit was hilarious.
It's going well.
thanks.
So,
uh,
when you,
you ready to do another one?
I'm getting,
I mean I'm doing my hour on the road now
is pretty solid.
Like I don't feel like I'm the crowd's
not getting to full good show.
But unlike siding when I want to do it,
I think I had to hold off till october
because I'm going to do an edinburgh.
Oh,
in edinburgh for a month.
Say it right though.
Don't say an burnham brook at mad
edinburgh like you fucker.
You wouldn't even from here steering on
me.
So I don't want to waste that time on
the material.
I'm going to run at 25 times in the uk.
I want to add that would make it
stronger.
Yeah,
we'll definitely adapt to that
environment to,
you know,
you get a groove,
like what audiences are like in
different countries.
New there for a few days.
Specially my last special I ran in 10
countries.
Wow.
Yeah.
I like,
you know,
getting it to everybody and see if it
works everywhere.
Smart move man.
It's smart because it,
you know,
you know how guys in one town they'll
develop a style suitable the one town
and we started on third street.
Yeah.
It might not work in chicago.
like what the fuck is third street?
I don't know what you're talking about.
I have a bit of a farmer brokers in New
York and it's like
I've got to make it work outside of New
York.
Yeah,
it's hard regional materials hard,
but every two weeks I'm gonna be my
storytelling.
Show the belly room.
19th is the next one and then whatever
should we accepted that?
But uh,
I've got irvine.
I'm doing my hour but I'll be in denver.
Are you the great.com or the great talk
conference tickets or ari shaffir.com in
the denver.
Was steve simone on the 28th,
29th,
30th or 31st comedy works at the
greatest club on the planet earth or one
of them?
Indianapolis.
Tempe.
Everything's great.
Everything's already the great.com.
Oh,
read the motherfucking grade.com.
And if you like sports,
check out the sports pockets.
Sam tripoli and jason tebow called
punchdrunk sports.
Oh,
that's right.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Nate diaz.
Nick diaz calling all the time.
How about the scepter esp skeptic tank,
your podcast skeptic tank.
That's right.
There's another good ones.
Got a fucking podcast to this week's
coming up later today I guess is the
irish affair interview by danish?
No,
neil good.
Google-y mooglie.
Ladies and gentlemen.
All right,
that's it.
He doesn't do it.
Sometimes I do.
I listen to your podcast all the time.
That's cool.
Can I get fox?
We love you.
See you tomorrow.
Bye.